[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prends le relais ce qu'on m'en fous
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
champion de chaise tour l'édition
Cup et aujourd'hui on aura le grand
plaisir d'entendre Stéphane probablement
et surtout de suivre enfin non surtout
aussi de suivre évidemment allez résa
firja qui sera là et Jules Moussa qui
s'est qualifié pour cette division
tandis que j'ai échoué mon cher mon cher
stuff aux portes de la division 3
divisions 3 qui me correspondait bien
mais en tout cas on a des très beaux
matchs aujourd'hui avec cette division
est notamment Ali resa qui va jouer face
à Collard un invité surprise de ce de ce
dernier de ces quarts de finale avec
quand même simplement huit joueurs donc
qui ont réussi à se qualifier pour cette
division 1 et Jules qui est aussi un
demi invité surprise qui jouera face à
Abdou sa torov qu'on avait qu'on avait
suivi hier qu'on a suivi hier faut pas
qu'on a vraiment n'importe quoi qu'on a
essuyé au dernier tournoi face à Maxime
va chez Lagrave et qui avait fait une
performance assez extraordinaire en ne
laissant aucune chance au numéro 2
français donc on va voir on va voir tout
ça champion du monde de Bleach
évidemment notre ami Maxime
et donc ça va être ça va être très très
sympa à suivre avec deux Français sur 8
c'est quand même une très très belle
performance et on aura peut-être vu là
Jules nous a dit qu'il venait peut-être
en fin de en fin de stream pour
débriefer sa journée donc évidemment on
va suivre c'est peut-être le plus beau
match qu'on a aujourd'hui Jul contre ce
jeune Abdou Sator offensé champion du
monde rapide Stéphane c'est ça va pas
être facile il va falloir qu'il joue qui
soit son top tout simplement alors je
crois qu'on m'entendre maintenant j'ai
eu un problème de micro tout d'un coup
et ben mon micro ne répondez pas alors
normalement on devrait avoir les parties
qui commencent à 17h et il est déjà à
17h17 et je ne mange qu'une partie qui
s'affiche donc ça devrait arriver
j'imagine
très très bientôt en tout cas on
l'espère et
voilà c'est le premier jour c'est comme
d'habitude on rappelle un petit peu
peut-être la formule rapidement donc
c'est c'est quatre parties de de 15 + 3
s'il y a partout c'est cette fameuse
formule très intéressante où on met le
coup sous enveloppe le pouce on fait une
enchère sous enveloppes pour prendre les
Noirs dans l'Armageddon donc voilà par
exemple s'il est si ils arrivent à deux
partout Jules mais 11 minutes pour avoir
les noirs et adoucator of mais 10
minutes à ce moment-là Abdou ça te fera
10 minutes compte 15 les Noirs mais en
tout cas il pourra faire nul en cas de
nul ce sont les noirs qui gagnent c'est
le principe de l'Armageddon et à noter
aussi la particularité de ce format
c'est qu'on a le droit à une mauvaise
journée Stéphane si on a une mauvaise
journée et bien on peut se refaire c'est
double éliminations et donc voilà ça tu
attends on avait vu lors de la question
précédente on avait vu quinzaine qui
avait perdu il me semble lors du premier
match qui avait rejoint au final
Nakamura en finale malgré le fait qu'ils
étaient
faits éliminés
tout à fait il avait rejoué il avait
rejoué ensuite Nakamura Nakamura qui est
ensuite battu caroanna et dans le
premier tournoi de ce Champions il y en
aura six sept années c'était Magnus
Carson qui avait emporté sans perdre un
seul match donc grosse perf de Magnus
mais pas de Magnus dans ce tournoi donc
ça laisse un petit peu le champ libre
toujours en a toujours la caméra dans
cette division 1 évidemment on a failli
à nos car wanna qui a très très bien
joué depuis le départ de ce champions et
des nouvelles têtes avec notamment
Collard shimanov alors la shimanov pour
moi c'est une c'est une énorme surprise
je l'avais joué il y a quelques années
en Corse donc
voilà ça permet à des joueurs de se
qualifier dans ces dans ces Open en fait
ces open ouvert ce playing ouvert au
grand maître
et donc shimanov Colars qui sont un peu
des surprises on ailleur dan van forest
qui est certainement pas une surprise
Jules évidemment qui est une petite
surprise et à lireza qui fait partie
peut-être favori numéro 2 derrière Naka
parce que Naka cette cadence il est
toujours favori Stéphane il me semble
donc
il est dur de ne pas mettre favoris et
après c'est comme ça il est il est top
en ce moment aussi ouais toujours top
c'est vrai bon alors après il a fait
comme il dit il a fait un début d'année
réussie donc au grand festo à Bucarest
en partie longue où il a fait un demi
pot en dessous de la moyenne donc 5 sur
9 bon début d'année Ali resa fin mai
alors c'est pas tout à fait le début de
l'année normalement mais bon c'est vrai
que c'était son premier tour de l'année
donc c'est un peu c'est un peu bizarre
avec ces postes de six mois et parfois
il a il a tendance à dire à parler de
début d'année en mai mais voilà il est
quand même en forme et d'ailleurs il se
maintient en forme grâce à ses tournois
qui joue régulièrement du Championship
tour ou en gros si c'est pas la division
1 en général il joue pas tout simplement
donc beaucoup d'ambition chez Ali resa
qui va jouer collars bon normalement
c'est ils devront faire normalement il
devrait en faire qu'une bouchée on va
pas
dire
mais
ok
ça face à face à mais bon
on verra
on verra bien envoie les joueurs qui
sont pas là donc il y a peut-être un
léger léger souci mais vous inquiétez
pas ça va commencer et leur mission
d'être de Jules bah on lui posera plein
de questions il va nous rejoindre
franchement 56 mais allez je fais son je
fais son porte-parole et l'ambition de
Jules d'être 2700 plus toujours
envisageable bien sûr et donc toute
façon ça reste ça reste son ambition
quoi d'autre il a il a eu un petit coup
de mou hein ces derniers temps été noté
par Fontenoy 56 qui sait les coups de
mou en général ils se traduisent par des
pertes de poids lourds
donc ça arrive mais voilà il reste
encore très jeune et donc
oui très très envisageable d'avoir plus
de 2016 d'ailleurs la preuve qualifier
dans ce tournoi pour la division 1
c'était quand même pas si évident bah
oui alors d'ailleurs est-ce que tu
connais les joueurs qui font partie de
la division 1 cette saison
cette saison là
je connais tous alors on a Hikaru
Nakamura Fabiano caroana Ali Reza pire
rouge à ça fait trois Abdou Sator of
Moussa shimanov Collard et voilà je
savais qu'il allait me manquer
c'est toujours comme ça et Van forest
pardon
dans la dans la première division
qu'est-ce que tu veux
c'est très très dur il y a quelque chose
et on voit peut-être aussi Shimano enfin
qui a tu vois pour moi c'est une
surprise parce qu'il a quand même il a
2600 hello tu vois il a jamais été un
expert de des rapides et des bits mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il fait beaucoup
beaucoup de strips et donc énormément de
Blitz online et voilà on fait des
progrès donc cette cadence à 10 + 2 tout
simplement la pratique c'est en train de
démontrer que finalement c'est streamer
qui font des blistes toute la journée
et bien finalement ils font des progrès
en plus ce qui est pas une si grosse
surprise mais c'est intéressant de voir
ce développement quand même je pensais
pas moi honnêtement parce que tu étais
en train de parler tu es en train de
faire autre chose mais en fait c'est
quand même c'est quand même très utile
c'est difficile enfin moi pour streamer
je te dis j'ai perdu des points et l'eau
depuis que je stream
et on s'habitue à peu près mais c'est
pas pareil quoi ouais mais moi j'avais
fait plein j'avais fait plein du temps
de chaise 24 des ventes j'en ai fait
énormément
des stream où je parlais mais ouais je
jouais mal quand même globalement dans
ces dans ces bandera je jouais pas du
tout à mon niveau mais bon après si on
fait vraiment ça cinq six heures par
jour pendant des années peut-être que
oui peut-être que certains possible
qu'on fasse des progrès et ça a l'air en
tout cas
ouais et pour Naka qui joue pas les
viewer en fait on accueil joue pas les
over il cherche à vraiment à jouer des
bons joueurs tout le temps
toujours très bien préparé il peut il
leur donne faut absolument qu'il fasse
mal dans les ouvertures à anaka Jules on
va voir Julie m'a dit que
je veux un peu de tout surtout sur
Internet
voilà il s'adapte beaucoup à son
adversaire donc on va voir
bon bah pourquoi ça ça s'appelle cheskid
sur XOS show alors Chelsea qu'est-ce que
c'est et bien c'est un site de
chaise.com ou on peut les enfants
peuvent apprendre à jouer aux échecs de
manière ludique
voilà donc
cheskids même d'ailleurs c'est qui
le Nord
tu peux aller voir si tu as des enfants
mon cher sur le moment de mettre aux
échecs
et surtout ils se saute tu ne donnes
aucun conseil à tes enfants
allez voir très très beau site que j'ai
regardé vraiment sympa si vous voulez je
vous mets la petite la petite vidéo
pendant que je termine ça
[Musique]
va être la deuxième là j'ai là je ne
sais trois vidéos avec R6 en premier
cheesed et ensuite manuscrit c'est la
deuxième à tout de suite
[Musique]
avec les Blancs contre Dimitri Collard
donc donc ok pour l'instant c'est une
position assez standard tout ce qu'il y
a de plus normal ou c'est vrai que le
Coust standard c'est de bloquer les
chèques avec le fou de case noire en D2
bon ça a été bloqué avec le cavalier
c'est une légère sous variante mais ça
reste quand même une des lignes tout à
fait principale
il va falloir essayer juste de sortir
certainement Colars de ces de ces prépas
ça va être l'enjeu de ses premiers coups
parce qu'on sent dans le jeu un Collard
c'est normalement il y a aucune chance
hein contre Ali raisin
donc voilà c'est comme ça que je en tout
cas c'est comme ça un peu de Colars
c'est comme ça que j'aborderai ce match
d'essayer de faire le plus forcer
possible
voilà trois on pose la question
au fou
et
ouais ok
je sais pas donc là normalement on prend
des deux on prend des deux ici on peut
reculer aussi pour jouer pour jouer
ensuite c'est cette C5 on va être c'est
tout à fait c'est une catalane tout à
fait standard entre les deux joueurs
donc il a pris le pion ouais bon ça
c'est très thématique on donne le pion
c'est vous voyez pour la paire de fou et
une majorité au centre
et encore une fois c'est très théorique
donc
évidemment les Blancs ont du jeu
pour le pion est-ce que ça va être assez
c'est quasiment certain est-ce que ça va
être plus cassé ça dépend des prochains
coups
il faut voir il faut voir ce que font ce
que font les Noirs ici je dois avouer
que je connais pas la théorie peut-être
peut-être E5 pour essayer de rendre le
pion tout de suite et essayer de sortir
ce fou de casse blanche qui peut être
très très mal placé en C8 et ne pas voir
le jour
et je tombais 8 donc il a l'air toujours
dans sa prépa Colars quelle idée de tour
B8 et bien évidemment c'est de jouer B7
B5 sans être dans la grande diagonale la
diagonale H1 à 8 où il y a ce fou en G2
typique de la catalane qui rayonne et
donc avant de jouer B5 on enlève cette
tour par précaution tout simplement et
on va s'accrocher au pion c'est à peu
près clair maintenant ce qu'il veut
faire qui veut faire Collard
tranquillement et finalement que le foot
en jeu de bah ça ça vachement de sens de
vouloir ça coule sur le pion en plus il
y a trois qui étaient joués hein à 3
c'est aussi un coup qui a fait plus
quand même pas mal les cases blanches
autour du pion C4 donc imaginons après
un B5 et puis je sais pas un jour si
jamais j'arrive alors ma cavalier vers
vers à 5 B3 par exemple ça peut être pas
mal
ouais non ça peut devenir très bien pour
les noirs a priori on a largement assez
de jeu quand même parce que justement ce
que tu disais les cases blanches sont
faits mais c'est vrai que pour aller à
5b pour aller en B3 faut passer par A5
ou par D4 enfin il y a pas trop de il y
a pas trop de passage pour l'instant et
en général
[Musique]
et en général c'est compliqué de d'avoir
ça on va voir cette position très
complexe qui devrait bien correspondre à
les hasards Collard bon hello il est
jeune tout à fait c'est un jeune joueur
allemand qui a à peu près qui doit
2630-2640 et qui a une vingtaine
d'années donc ouais la cette équipe
allemande qui est en plein
renouvellement là clairement avec
notamment en fer de lance que j'ai vu
aux Olympiades donc Wissant gamer il y a
collars qui est là
il y a blueba qui doit être dans la
division 2 ou 3 enfin ils ont une ils
ont une jeune équipe et donc les
Allemands qui reviennent en force
clairement comme une grande nation
comme une grande nation qui se battra
pour les médailles que ce soit aux
Olympiades au championnat d'Europe et
salut à toi robinside
ouais c'est cheesekid en fait c'est vrai
que moi j'ai appelé Robinson il fait la
même erreur que moi ça me rassure pas
pour le community management mais ça
sera sur moi
c'est cheesekid en fait je fais aussi
j'arrêtais pas de dire cheese kids et en
fait c'est cheese kids
la majorité du site est traduite en
français
Stéphane donc c'est quand même c'est
très très bien
tout ce qui est traduction c'est Robin
side qui s'en occupe c'est robinsight
qui a traduit ça
traducteur officiel enfin on a plusieurs
traducteurs d'ailleurs à pièces comme
c'est Sami qui traduit généralement les
articles et après la plateforme
elle-même je sais pas mais enfin je sais
pas trop mais ok ça a mis samy est là
et donc il a fait à 4 ans pour empêcher
ce plan et donc il assiste il joue à 6 à
4 à 6 donc il veut vraiment faire
baisser après apparemment
et si je fais ici le petit coup à 5 avec
les Blancs et ben peut-être qu'on pourra
quand même faire baisser 5
je pense que tu vas être obligé en fait
parce que ton tout tes derniers coups la
tour B8 à 6 ont du sens que si tu jouais
5 de toute façon donc il faut absolument
le faire
beaucoup de monde ne connaît pas donc
c'est un coup très très important dans
plein de positions ça paye ici la prise
en passant donc quand on bouge un pion
de deux cases et qu'on se retrouve à
côté d'un pion adverse et ben le pion
adverse a le droit seulement à ce coup
là de manger en B6 et d'ailleurs je me
rappelle pas si tu l'as vu la petite
vidéo c'était en direct sur pièce
2400 fait rire à l'époque la
présentation qui ne marchait pas et
voilà
c'est un bug lifetviewer c'est le défaut
hein moi pour l'avoir utilisé ce live
chaise viewer de chaise 24 c'est le
défaut quand tu as des développeurs qui
jouent pas du tout aux échecs parfois ça
pose des petits problèmes sur les règles
du jeu qui sont pas toujours très bien
assimilés par les non joueurs d'échec ce
qui paraît
effectivement assez assez logique
cheeskid ah ouais tu vois pas de chess
kids ouais ouh là et ouais c'est ça
est-ce que ça marche
kids Dotcom ça renvoie sur quoi et non
ça on va sur cheesekid
c'est bizarre d'ailleurs on va voir on
va voir notre ami Jules qui a commencé
aussi allez on peut le faire un petit
tour
le champion de France c'est indépendant
de chaise comme cheskid juste des
partenaires et je vais vous changer les
noms en direct ah ouais
tu es sûr de ça
tu le dis
parce que j'avais compris pour le coup
mais possible après ça dépend si tu
considères indépendant est-ce que tu
considères que le chessable est
indépendante c'est ça la question aussi
donc on a notre ami Jules qui est là
dans son domicile parisien
19e arrondissement
et on voit il a les noirs
qui a joué une antisisienne ma foi pas
très très ambitieuse mais c'est ce qui
faisait à Maxime il jouait des il a un
nom il a un an notre Ami je pense que je
vais lui je vais l'enlever son prénom
tellement il mérite voilà c'est pas
mieux comme ça
il a un nom assez
donc entre Jules ouais donc une antise
Sicilienne bon mais Julie qui prend son
temps c'est du 15 + 3 donc ces joueurs
là il faut pas rater les débuts et joue
cahier des 7 logique j'ai l'impression
qu'on est assez E5 avec les blancs mais
ça c'est pas un coup qui peut surprendre
a priori Abdou sa torov
peut-être que c'est trois ou quatre
à base de C4 qui s'appelle
le maroczi et donc E4 C4 c'est la
structure de pion contre la Sicilienne
thématique très solide et là il a joué
avec dernier 3 pics avalé C3 donc c'est
un petit peu bah c'est souligne c'est
pas un truc qui sont très répandus mais
l'idée que tu viens de proposer avec C3
plus tard donc avaler des 5 cavalier au
centre c'est très bien et ces trois pour
jouer un peu contre le foot quasiment le
fou qui va buter contre cette belle
chaîne de pions des blancs donc ce fou
est très fort dans toutes les positions
donc essaie de jouer contre ce fou c'est
intéressant
ça cassait pas trois pattes à un canard
bon mais voilà on est d'accord je crois
que c'est le genre de début qui casse
pas trois pattes à un canard
effectivement
mais bon d'un F4 d'un H4 ou H6 écoute
peut avoir une petite embellie il faut
faire quand même un petit peu attention
avec les Noirs
c'est pas forcément
cool de se prendre une attaque comme ça
très très vite d'entrée de jeu tu vois
disons que il faut quand même réagir
quoi c'est pas c'est ok ça a pas l'air
d'être très effrayant mais bon
il faut quand même faire un petit peu
attention quoi mais Jules je pense ma
coupe avoir confiance en lui
et non évidemment il le voit venir ce
genre de truc ça c'est clair
donc pas évident d'ailleurs je sais pas
parce que si je joue le coup naturel on
peut essayer fou B7
et maintenant comment je fais
tout 8 pour faire foi 6 fois 8 mais
pareil beaucoup trop risqué
alors mais peut-être que
tu vois comment
[Musique]
ça peut arriver vite ça peut arriver
très vite alors peut-être si peut-être
vous prendre les deux tu sais autant
autant savoir pourquoi tu vois au moins
on est une raison de souffrir ça fait un
pion
après
G5
on l'a déjà fait cette j'ai l'impression
pour être très honnête donc ouais ça
craint un petit peu là pour je suis
curieux de voir son prochain coup qui va
définir les suivants vous voyez c'est un
moment c'est un moment critique
et ok
enlever des pièces exactement c'est
souvent dans ces positions par exemple
de Grand Prix par exemple souvent on va
essayer échanger les cavaliers si on
peut pour éviter les actions sur le roi
direct donc après ça
et je pense qu'on peut pas faire damage
parce que il y a qu'à F3 échec foot F3
et cavalier des 4 attaque le pion C2 et
le faux F3
et là ca va les prendre ok
elle a un petit peu moins bas elle est
plus elle est beaucoup moins
impressionnante qu'avant parce qu'il y a
plus qu'à valler le 5 déjà et le fou
c'est 4 a du mal à venir et après le
fait de jouer F4 pour Jason cavalier
c'est pas toujours toujours bon parce
que bah ça ouvre la diagonale blanche et
des fois en plus avec le pion F4 et moi
le foie du mal à bouger
donc avoir
on est venu là pour ça quand même H4
semble être le coup normal
je te pose une question parce que si tu
dois jouer F6 bah ça a pas de plaire
avec ton four en G7 a priori c'est pas
un truc que tu as envie de faire
naturellement tu aurais pas fait de
toi-même en tout cas ça c'est le minimum
mais en fait il faut savoir parce que
sur ça moi le coup qui va m'embête c'est
c'est ça peut être F4 parce que j'ai pas
de bonne case souvent dans le dans les
potions de dragon sur F4 on aime bien
mettre le cavaler en C4 le problème
c'est qu'on se mangé donc il faut et là
j'ai pas besoin de faire tourner en fait
parce que si je pouvais faire torcer
vite maintenant la F4 qui est C4 est bon
ça a l'air d'aller je reviens en 17 avec
mon cavalier c'est pas très grave parce
que je vois pas trop le l'attaque
finalement je ferai passer le fou
d'abord je sais pas on finit
parce que
et tu vas me forcer à verser en fait
ouais et si je crois que si je te force
à faire la vie c'est pour ça que j'ai
l'impression qu'ici le coup pour les
Noirs c'est ça ça va être fou aussi
pourquoi faut aussi s'en alors qu'on a
joué au fou B7 vous baisser comme ça
j'aurais [__] en dessin tant pis oui
il faut aussi non on vient de jouer B6
quand même on va pas exagérer on va être
raisonnable remarque il faut regarder
fouger 5 F4 qui est fou j'ai 5 tours 8
est-ce qu'il y a fou B5 qui marche c'est
ça qui doit regarder un jus là faut B5
peut être dangereux hein tu peux perdre
du matériel ici on va on va peut-être
montrer une petite tactique que les
joueurs doivent voir il voit 110
secondes ok 17 ok 17 si elle te reprend
des 6
donc voilà on voit déjà il y a des
thèmes de clouage qui peuvent être
désagréables poussez si il y a peut-être
rêve 4 qui marche il faut regarder F4 il
faut prendre les 5 je peux prendre je
peux prendre ça comme tu ouais ouais ça
ça peut être très très chaud et quand tu
t'en fous ben en plus tu as pas de bonne
cadre parce que là j'ai même tout
reprend des 6 encore j'ai même eux
prendre des six vous voyez le cloche qui
est qui est très très embêtant quoi
ok on va revenir un petit peu au live
parce qu'il y a eu des coups il a fait
Jules ils sont à match 4 il a juste
avaler des quatre un peu la même idée
que tu avais vu tout à l'heure
on a passé des heures et des heures à
commenter on recommence on va
recommencer ensemble dimanche prochain
et oui dimanche prochain au chasboxing
je savais parler la dernière fois
on sera à 7 dans cette belle ville de
Sète n'hésitez pas à venir si vous êtes
dans les alentours à 7 ça va être très
sympa on passe des bonnes soirées et on
voit du Chase boxing donc qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un peu d'échec un peu de
boxe tout ça très très beau sport donc
en fait quand même faut voir les types
ils jouent enfin les types les chess
boxeurs donc il y a il y a des champions
du monde français donc le plus connu
Thomas Cazeneuve qui est quand même très
très fort et bien il joue il joue aux
échecs en ayant pris
en ayant fait quand même pas mal salle
de sport on est appris éventuellement
des coûts donc voilà c'est un côté
très divertissant et très sympa
voilà donc n'hésitez pas si vous êtes
dans le coin à venir à venir sur 7 et on
commentera avec Jules voilà ça sera le
retour on va on l'a déjà fait en 2019 le
chaise boxing on va le refaire cette
fois ça leur sympa j'aimerais bien un
jour assisté à un match je te le
conseille et
il y a le truc il y a l'ambiance autour
tu vois qui est quand même très sympa
avec des joueurs d'échec des gens qui
s'intéressent à la boxe et des gens qui
s'intéressent un peu aux deux tu vois et
donc voilà
c'est vraiment faux ah faut le prendre
comme un spectacle en fait
même si c'est pas le déchets en fait
c'est enfin savoir quoi tiens un Samy
qui sera apparemment Robinson
on se verra cette occasion
et il habite dans le coin tu viens
exprès qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu
viens faire là-bas je crois qu'il va
participer je crois qu'il joue il va
participer super j'adore
[Rires]
non non il y a même il y a des twitchers
connus comme comme ça voilà qui fait ça
qui joue qui s'est mis à la boxe on
verra en tout cas ça sera sympa
n'hésitez pas à venir voir ça
bref c'était pour parler de notre duo
avec Jules donc faut F6 jouer par Jules
qui serait d'accord avec une avec une
répétition évidemment mais a priori on
va faire fouger ça quand même
des fois ça m'arrive
c'est bon non attends j'ai un faux
contact
excuse-moi
comment je fais officiel mais bien sûr
moi tu sais chez Robinson qui commentait
officiel mais évidemment enfin écoute tu
m'as vu je vais pas commenter depuis ma
voiture pas de voiture en plus donc
voilà commentaire officiel oui du chaos
boxing commentateur officiel avec Jules
des échecs c'est on s'y connaît moi et
quoi que Jules il s'y connaît en boxe tu
sais qu'il serait il se fait chauffer à
chaque fois par le par le président de
la fédération de chaise boxing qui vient
d'un très bon œil évidemment l'arrivée
de Jul parce que Jul a fait quelques
années de boxe
il est pas mal
et à la boxe il peut te enfin il est bon
aussi quoi enfin il est pas oui
évidemment bon pas aux échecs la boxe
mais
il y a potentiel tu vois s'il arrive à
prendre les coups
de chaque il peut te mettre du coup quoi
enfin pas 10 mais
tu vois non moi j'avais vu en fait je
sais pas toi qu'est-ce que tu en penses
par rapport au chaos boxing est-ce que
c'est mieux d'être un très bon échec ou
d'être
un mec hyper caisse non vaut mieux être
très bon joueur d'échec parce que tu
commences par les échecs et donc c'est
souvent comme les rando boxe sont assez
courts il y a très peu de il y a très
peu de chaos j'ai vu très très peu de
chaos et même c'est ce que me disait
chaise boxer c'est que c'est quand même
l'avantage au joueur d'échec voilà la
formule en tout cas peut-être que ça a
changé hein tu sais on sait jamais en
tout cas pour l'instant la formule comme
elle est vu le nombre de minutes où tu
joues aux échecs et la durée des rampes
de boxe c'est quand même avantage
avantage joueur d'échec
donc
voilà pour la question de de docteur
Stone
échec c'est pas mal moi j'avais vu
j'avais vu c'était l'article je crois
qu'il y avait alors je sais pas si
c'était
[Musique]
c'est déjà il a 2100 2100 2150 qui
m'excuse si je me trompe en fidélité
peut-être qu'il a même un peu plus mais
alors il a il s'entraîne online c'est
pas un client ambulette et compagnie
c'est même un très sérieux client tu
vois c'est bien il y a plus de 10 ans
hein et ben on jouait beaucoup Boston
sur un autre site à l'époque un vieux
site il y a très longtemps et je me
souviens d'avoir joué beaucoup beaucoup
de Bullet avec lui et oui
j'espère qu'il a changé depuis
mais
ouais ouais ça m'étonne pas que c'est un
très bon genre de bling et c'est
évidemment quand tu te prends en fait je
sais pas moi je me suis jamais battu je
me suis jamais battu je me suis jamais
je me suis jamais battu et je me suis
jamais José chèques après m'être battu
mais je pense que quand tu quand tu
prends des des coups de poing comme ça
je pense que les réflexes évidemment euh
archi important non mais tu vois tu es
là en fait juste les réflexes la main
c'est la main qui joue je suppose ouais
ouais mais même en plus c'était
j'imagine que tu peux être un peu sonné
et puis en plus tu as le fait de de
d'être fatigué la fatigue enfin tu vois
il y a plein de choses qui je pense
qu'ils font que tu joues pas forcément
aussi bien ah oui ça c'est sûr et
heureusement après à quel point ça peut
influer sur ton niveau etc on peut faire
pas savoir
il est plus grand que moi mais bon je
suis plus tenu pour toi je me je
m'entraîne pour toi je m'entraîne pour
toi ouais mais attends mais toi tu es
attends mais moi je suis pas lourd par
rapport à toi par contre c'est ça je
vais te désagréable mais
c'est ça faut quand même une alors on va
pas on va pas donner nos poids à
l'antenne mais
il était plus grand que moi en plus
il y a pas de il y a pas de cas mais aux
échecs que moi donc écoute
voilà donc ça c'est un truc très sympa
bon mais Jules il est quand même c'est
un peu moins sympa sa position on voit
il grimaceouille un petit peu il menace
ici il a eu son cavalier en D4 qui avait
plus de cases donc il veut clairement
jouer cavalier D4 F5
très bien joué qui était parce qu'en
fait il y avait peut-être tu peux le
montrer au coup d'avant s'il y a pas la
d'avance c'est 8 c'est de ces trois si
on joue un coup de lambda avec les Noirs
il y a ces deux C3 qui gagne une pièce
tout simplement donc fallait il fallait
quand même s'organiser hein voilà donc
très sympa et je crois que sur
MG4 moi j'ai un peu peur de MG4 pour
prendre toutes les cases et j'ai
l'impression il y a quel prend C2 ici
4 OK
et je retire mon cavalier soit en B4 en
décapant
OK
ule cavalier mais il est pas de cases de
fuite c'est ça le problème donc il a
joué dans F4 ok est-ce qu'on peut
prendre le pion C2 je crois pas
je crois pas du tout
simplement moins moins fort est-ce que
j'ai ah non mais non ça marche pas du
tout dame prend C2 mais en fait je suis
fou prends et cavalier d'or ensuite le
cavalier F4 est en prise à la fin à la
fin de la variante
ça marche pas mais
en Bullet c'est le bluff
au début tu sais ce que j'ai vu je me
suis dit il y a dame prend des quatre et
je gagne une pièce mais en fait
il faut prendre quatre on gagne mais en
fait il y a juste il y a juste fou
français d'eux
et en fait d'un point sur le marché
de j'ai une fourchette mais après
qu'elle va les prendre
une pièce mais cela était pas défendu
ben prends celle-là ça aurait pu être
donc en tout cas ça montre que le thème
des thèmes en l'occurrence je pense que
ce qui veut faire il voulait juste jouer
C3 au prochain coup et avoir cette
finale avantageuse sur cavalier F5
comprend F5 et on a les pions doubler
alors qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici est-ce
qu'on joue peut-être moi je pense un
dame F5 mais j'ai peur de me faire
arnaquer
mais peut-être que tu as le truc que la
dame 3 et Madame elle est attaquée elle
est plus beaucoup de cases peut-être
qu'elle c'est maman de d'attaquer un
petit peu ce fou et de de venir me
réorganiser mais c'est vrai ce cavalier
en 24 il a pas de bonne case il est pas
stable il est pas stable
ce serait quand même bien bien mieux
mais bon peut-être cavalier F5 fou bouge
donc je sais pas trop où aller te
prendre des deux
et essayer de trouver une case pour ce
les blancs sont bien en plus regardent
le temps le temps que je sais que tu
regardes le temps mais 4 minutes
simplement pour Jules et bien sous
pression là qu'on est 7 minutes Abdou ça
te offre
c'est pas facile et il fait une bonne
partie hein il y a pas à dire
il met bien la pression là
ouais donc on va voir on va voir ce
qu'il fait Jules
alors c'est quoi le problème sur
cavalier F5 juste faire fouder 2 ben je
vais bouger mon fou quelque part je sais
pas où
et puis mon cavalier bon il est pas
attaqué
attaquable il peut mais bon ça affaiblit
quand même aussi mais dans notre côté il
est pas stable j'aimerais bien pouvoir
le mettre en E5 par exemple mais bon
c'est c'est un peu long
enfin carrément changé
ah bah oui mais bon ça
en fait je pense que c'est une position
qui est difficile il faut y aller à un
moment donné il faut pas attendre comme
ça il faut il faut manger les pions
parce qu'au moins du coup
exactement
comme le 5 ça va ouvrir la porte
des des trucs pour m'activer avec mes
pièces
je crois que là c'est pas facile il faut
trouver des cours
de Jules à 120 il a 2730 Jules il est
aux alentours là il a il a perdu
beaucoup de points de 2650 mais il était
pas loin de 2007 il y a pas si longtemps
on va pas se mentir clairement Abdou
satorof un profil de probable
futur candidats au titre mondial voir
futur champion du monde donc ce qui est
là pas je la passe profil là
plutôt un profil de joueur à plus de
2007 donc bon voilà ça sera un bel
exploit à la part de Jules de d'arriver
à battre Abdou aujourd'hui
alors il a fait aussi quand même
d'accord
c'est vrai que d'un côté il faut bien
qu'il fasse quelque chose
et d'un autre côté quand on a la perte
quand elle a peur de fou enfin quand tu
joues contre la part de foot tu vas
essayer de pas trop ouvrir la position
et c'est ce qu'il fait et en plus sur
cash blanchir les trous et que il manque
le cadence avec les Noirs d'ailleurs
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu mettre la vue
depuis les noirs pour la prochaine à la
prochaine on fera ça ouais mais c'est
vrai que c'est clairement pas de gaieté
de cœur qu'il a fait ça mais c'est faute
de mieux parce qu'on fait pas ce genre
de choses
par goût tout simplement on fait ce
genre de choses parce qu'on a pas
vraiment le choix et qu'on voit pas trop
quoi faire et que le temps la pendule la
pendule tourne regardez la Mb4 commencer
à commencer à attaquer les pions et
c'est ce qu'avait dit qu'un pauvre tu
vois après dame C6 typiquement ce
qu'elle dit carpool l'avantage de la
paire de fou c'est qu'on peut s'en
séparer d'un quand on veut par exemple
si je fais [__] F5 ici je vais prendre
5 x 3 j'attaque de pions
j'attaque B6 j'attaque des six comment
tu les protège pour moi c'est pas très
clair c'est ce genre de question
peut-être c'est un peu tôt aussi pour
faire [__] F5 mais c'est ce genre de
question auquel Jules va devoir répondre
ça va pas être évident
typique essayer de faire un truc comme
ça alors je sais pas si je peux essayer
de penser
après tu as un peu de jeu c'est
probablement un peu tôt dame prend V6
on va voir ce qui va et qui va choisir
ça me semble un peu de tous là dit mais
bon à d'où ça te ref c'est pas le genre
à pas calculer tu vois si tu en es pas
il a joué il ajoute la suite
et il veut se venger directement sur la
sur le pion B2 avec d'un B6 prise
pour les blancs donc je crois qu'en fait
il est juste content tu vois il libère
un peu la pression la position la plus
facile à jouer bon le problème c'est
qu'il manque un pion mais à la limite tu
as le centre bon
je sais pas je crois je crois que c'est
pas une si mauvaise décision pratique
pour les pour les noix
évidemment évidemment qui va devoir
défendre mais de toute façon sa position
était pas très bonne
quand même quand tu manges un pion
ou tu préfères celle-là toi
moi je change toujours
j'ai peur sur
ebay 8 c'est peut-être pour ça que je
pense que effectivement je suis d'accord
avec toi vaut mieux changer dame mais je
pense que les noirs sont pas obligés
peut-être que c'est d'ailleurs c'est
probablement ce que je l'avais vu l'âme
D7 faut être mauvais coup d'après la
jauge qui n'aime pas ça
pourquoi parce qu'il aime pas ça je ne
sais pas en tout cas c'est un coup qui
avait l'air assez standard on va essayer
de ça c'est parce que pour eb8
pour cloué ou tu rabb8 il y avait
simplement le coup A4 à 5 avec les
Blancs qui cimenté se fout en B6 donc on
commence parfois vite qui a l'air
complètement normal mais qui est pas bon
bon pourquoi pourquoi parce que
peut-être que le chou blanc va revenir
en D4 maintenant je sais pas
c'est ça d'accord ok côté humain ça a
l'air bien mais apparemment c'est pas
bon du tout c'est calme ouh là là ces
quatre peut faire très mal fou prends
est-ce qu'il y a papillon prend des 5 à
intermédiaire non
et le roi et on voit hein pourquoi il
aimait pas du tout elle aimait pas du
tout la jauge parce que le fond je sais
c'est protéger très bien ce roi et moi
on voit maintenant ce roi qui en est
vraiment dans les courants d'air ici
donc après dame j'ai trois rois suite
qu'est-ce qu'on fait puis on prend des
cinq ou puis on prend le 6 d'abord je
sais pas
oh là là ça tourne ça tourne mal là pour
la première pour Jules pour essayer de
faire échec et de manger là directement
ou si on mange directement des cinq
comme tu l'as proposé ah je crois qu'on
fait après on V6 parce que si tu prends
qui fait apprendre aussi ici tu prends
quoi en C4 je crois que tu as rien tu as
rien puis on prend V6
il est très bien mais il laisse pas les
choses au hasard il réfléchit si tu fais
dame français un tour C7 j'ai un truc
qui va être très fort j'ai même échec
avec un tour là tu vois pas mal aussi
j'ai pas mal de très bons coups avec les
avec les Blancs là et si tu prends du
pion des je vais avoir je vais avoir au
minimum au minimum j'ai tout reprend
assise
quand même 5 3 G8 c'est ce que je peux
faire c'est une idée sur pion prend ces
quatre je vais faire dames 5 rois j'ai 8
3 pour montrer le potentiel quand même
de la position blanche tour à trois
monastères G3 à vendre
tu as tout compris
c'est le premier à deux et demi point et
s'il perd il va en loser bracket tout à
fait donc il peut encore gagner le
tournoi si il perd mais effectivement on
a droit on a une un seul droit à
l'erreur bon après presque la première
partie du premier du premier match donc
tout rien n'est grave pour le moment
elle est pas encore perdue quoi que très
très mal engagé on va pas se mentir là
il y a 5 3 G8 tour à 3
pendant que j'ai les résultats si tu
veux des autres matchs
on a Caravana qui a battu shimanov donc
c'était pas une surprise on en a
Nakamura qui a perdu contre van forest
ça c'est une belle première sortie
logiquement aussi contre Dimitri Colas
d'accord donc énorme surprise quoi que
attention et ordonne van forest on le
rappelle joueur il y a plus tout à fait
2007 mais il est pas loin il a gagné
Viken Zee
en
2017 9 ou 19 je crois donc c'était le
vainqueur surpris donc attention grosse
expérience de de Jordan notamment grâce
à ce tournoi
le Wimbledon des échecs vaikamsé qui
joue chaque année depuis de nombreuses
années maintenant et donc il est acquis
une grosse expérience en jouant contre
les meilleurs joueurs du monde et
finalement en ayant pris l'habitude de
les battre donc pour lui c'est pas c'est
pas un gros stress c'est un joueur
donc en fait c'est pour le coup c'est
bah c'est un joueur qui qui peut créer
la surprise bon il a gagné dans la
première partie c'est pas encore terminé
mais c'est un joueur qui qui peut
déstabiliser n'a qu'à quoi tu vois on
sent que sur je vois pas du tout gagner
ce tournoi mais par contre je le vois
euh ouais battre en jeu comme Dakar je
pense que c'est largement possible c'est
un joueur qui est qui est dangereux et
qui est capable de de de
perfe quoi
donc il a il a d'ailleurs des résultats
contre Magnus par exemple et donc c'est
un joueur qui qui est très très qui est
un style on va dire en tout cas très
je crois que eux ils sont quand même ils
se font rouler dessus quand même oui bon
c'est un peu normal mais moi je suis une
partie je crois que c'est un style
avec une position
[Musique]
et mais en tout cas bon c'est un genre
qui qui non non après il est il est
nettement moi j'ai des souvenirs de
session entraînement parce qu'il était
secondaire Magnus pour sur le dernier
match qu'on est Pau des sessions de
Blitz avec Magnus
qui se passait pas très bien pour yorden
on va pas se mentir
ça faisait de la peine à votre si tu
regardes bon moi j'étais content parce
qu'évidemment
ce qui joue à la fin tu vois donc tu as
plus de tout envie que ton poulain soit
en forme mais pour yorden c'était un peu
j'imagine que
très très impressionnant
donc on va suivre en tout cas la
revanche qui je pense va arriver d'ici
quelques instants
est-ce qu'on se fait une première page
de pub lorsque une première page de pub
et puis on revient très vite avec ce
magnifique tournoi quatre parties
décisives il faut que notre notre ami
Jules Moussa champion de France en titre
on le rappelle
ils reviennent tout de suite ou en tout
cas il faut pas qu'ils prennent l'eau
tout de suite donc ça serait bien que
les Blancs là abdos a fait une bonne
partie bon soit il reste il en reste
trois yes ça marche allez à tout de
suite je vous mets la petite pub un
petit peu de du R6 d'ailleurs tu pourras
aussi nous montrer si tu veux
regarde pourquoi tu crois que j'ai ce
temps aller et j'ai l'air si bonne forme
parce que j'ai un sims chez moi et
j'avais pas que j'en ai deux
et c'est la preuve que je ne mens jamais
voilà si c'est bleu c'est bon si c'est
rouge c'est pas bon donc voilà c'est
pour la qualité de l'air chez soi c'est
très important voir si tout va bien pour
la concentration
à cette époque du télétravail faut faire
attention aux conditions de travail donc
je vais vous mettre les pubs de RCX de
Chelsea et aussi de Magnus Carson
Academy donc vous allez voir un son
débat plus et ensuite je vous mettrai
une autre pub de ce coatlab c'est c'est
une richesse une vague c'est les chaises
de bureau si vous voulez
donc soit vous êtes Labs donc voilà
c'est Jean bassin et puis on se revoit
d'ici bah cinq petites minutes à tout de
suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Laurent
pour cette deuxième partie qui devrait
bientôt commencer d'ailleurs j'ai pas
fait les changements je voulais faire de
suite je remplace
donc ce qu'il passait dans cette
première partie on a Jules qui a perdu
avec les Noirs contre le jeune joueur
très talentueux nos libertés
qui c'est quand même un champion du
monde rapide 2021 champion olympique
avec la surprise la demi surprise parce
que nous les
équipes de jeunes là ils étaient quand
même dangereux mais quinzième élo sur la
grille de départ donc le leader le
leader de cette équipe ouzbek aller chez
quai numéro 1 qui a fait un super
tournoi je crois qu'il a fait sur il a
joué 10 parties il a gagné 5 parties et
fait 5000 enfin bon une Master Class au
premier échiquier et grosse partie là
encore une fois contre Jules bon pas
grand chose à faire quand quand joue
comme ça
et voilà donc victoire victoire méritait
d'Abdou Sator
rouge à l'autre français en liste numéro
français qui a battu Collard sans
surprise
ensuite on a une victoire de kerwana
face à shimanov ça c'est pas une
surprise non plus Stéphane mais alors la
dernière partie c'est Yarden van forest
qui a battu Hikaru Nakamura avec les
Noirs même dis donc il s'est permis luxe
de battre et Kawa avec les noirs
très très impressionnant bravo à lui
et donc quatre c'est l'avantage de ces
de ces parties rapides c'est qu'il y a
des résultats décisifs quasiment
quasiment tout le temps enfin en tout
cas il y a beaucoup de ça se barre ça
c'est sûr
ouais
dont une surprise vraiment sur ce match
là hein
Nakamura Nakamura c'est le vainqueur de
l'édition passée et le vainqueur en
finale contre Marius Carlson donc c'est
c'est pas n'importe qui et ensuite on
avait quand même des joueurs un peu plus
outsiders avec fil rouge qui bat comme
Collard
et Carola qui va chez manov donc c'est
le super joueur mais c'est vrai que
c'est des joueurs quand même qui sont
pas dans l'élite l'élite tu vois c'est
des gens à 2006 quoi et donc bien sûr
très fort joueur mais bon pour fuir
rouge là qui sont dans quasiment le top
5 mondial c'est envie de dire un peu une
formalité quoi et tout à fait et dans le
playing là je vois je salue nos amis de
YouTube sur sur chaise 24 en français ou
sur cheescom en français qui nous
regardent n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit pouce bleu à vous abonner à la
chaîne allez vous abonner sur chaise
comme fr quand même il y aura plus de
choses qui vont se passer dans le futur
là-bas c'est à peu près certain et oui
tout à fait pour ceux il y en a qui ont
suivi très bien c'est dans le chat Chase
24 en français effectivement Jul avait
perdu ce mini match contre Colars parce
qualifier pour la division 1 mais coup
de bol euh Annie je guéri et qui est le
chef
alors je sais pas ils ont joué ce tour
de calife pour un tournoi ok ils se sont
aperçu en fait qui ne pouvait pas
participer parce que il joue le grand
chaise tour en ce moment même alors
peut-être qu'il pensait que cheescom
allait changer les horaires le mettre le
soir et qu'il pouvait faire les deux je
sais pas quel était le raisonnement mais
en tout cas ils ont joué ils ont rejoint
le tournoi de qualif
pour se qualifier dans un tournoi final
oui il n'avait pas la possibilité de
jouer bon c'est particulier comme comme
concept mais pourquoi pas
à moins que ça commence rapide est-ce
que tu veux faire un petit tour
je vais vous montrer une petite image
d'abord je vais essayer de voir pour les
micros parce que là je crois que le tien
non ça va marcher
je vais passer dans cette salle là on
part pas en pause ne vous inquiétez pas
nous ne partons pas en pause pas
maintenant jamais hop
nous ne sommes pas en pause
parce que là je l'ai mis dans sa dans
celui-là
nous avons Magnus Carlsen qui qui a un
partenariat à nous partenariat avec Puma
qui font des super belles chaussures
vous voyez que il y a une petite dame
blanche sur la semaine de la chaussure
et donc voilà partenariat avec Puma et
une très belle photo donc on aura
peut-être d'ici la fin de la semaine
une vidéo avec un peu sorte de
partenariat etc et voilà donc je devais
vous la montrer en tout cas pour ceux
qui veulent des chaussures
Puma échec Carlson tout ça et ben
n'hésitez pas en tout cas on aura très
bientôt les liens de la boutique etc on
va revenir on va récupérer Laurent parce
qu'on a un petit peu abandonné je suis
désolé Laurent pas perdu pendant une
petite seconde il y a une question
idéale sur chaise 24 fr qui nous dit
Laurent as-tu des chaussures Puma Magnus
et non j'ai pas j'ai pas reçu elles sont
déjà sold out
si c'est déjà soldat out mais ça
m'étonne pas vous inquiétez pas Puma a
priori ils savent faire des affaires ils
vont en mettre
vous inquiétez pas si vous voulez
commander vous les trouverez
attends je vais mettre l'autre partie
alors 2650 on l'a dit 2150 à peu près
mais il vient d'en haut il était pas
loin de 2007 il y a pas très longtemps
et d'où ça te rend qui est aussi qui est
sur une grosse pente à ascendante avec
200730 où est-ce qu'il s'arrêtera et ben
c'est dur à dire parce que tellement il
dégage une grosse impression notre ami
[Musique]
notre ami Abdou Sator a vraiment très
très sérieux ouais 2150 en 4 en
classique ouais c'est un peu bon c'est
un peu ça
c'est un peu le bas de sa range comme on
dit donc voilà c'est un peu la même
forme on verra celui-là qui va qui va
certainement beaucoup plus jouer
ces prochains temps avec le Top 16 qui
arrive
d'ailleurs
tu en es où toi dans les préparatifs tu
te prépares un petit peu oh là
oh là non
voilà c'est un petit peu comme ton
testable
non mais je réfléchis je sais à peu près
je sais qu'elle répertoire je vais jouer
à peu près tu vois
après je vais faire des je vais essayer
que le problème c'est que je me souviens
pas des lignes concrètes tu vois il faut
les répéter beaucoup donc quelques jours
avant je vais peut-être commencer à
surtout avec les Noirs tu vois parce
qu'avec les blancs c'est jamais ce que
le type va jouer peut-être un peu avec
les Blancs aussi voir
faut un petit peu ce qui se passe parce
que
ouais il faut toujours réviser un petit
peu
mais effectivement je suis pas
[Musique]
non je suis pas dans le mot de là pour
l'instant mais ça va venir j'espère bien
j'en profite parce que j'ai vu au chat
sur le sur le stream et j'ai vu sa
participation en Top 16 enfin
j'ai tout suivi et j'aurais voulu la
féliciter pour pour
qualifié donc il y a Asnières on
retrouve un peu les mêmes que dans la
catégorie que le Top 16 donc il y a
Asnières Bischwiller hors demi-finale
Vandoeuvre petite surprise mais bon
vendeur ils font toujours mieux que ce
qu'on attend deux et Asnières
Bischwiller vendeur vraie et j'ai oublié
les quatrième qu'il m'en excuse je sais
plus qui c'est qualifié
de Monaco qui a été de nombreuses fois
l'équipe a été championne d'Europe de
nombreuses fois je pense cinq ou six
fois
qui est sorti ça m'a tout cassé
et il y en a certains qui
c'est vrai qu'il y avait
les partenariats mais c'est bien qu'on a
des partenaires comme Puma qui
s'intéressent aux échecs c'est quand
même assez extraordinaire il faut quand
même le reconnaître et les chaussures
sont sympas moi je trouve franchement
tu aimerais bien
à la partie de Jules qui a qui a pas
encore commencé elles ont toutes
commencé sauf celle de Jules on peut on
peut aller voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe c'est chez notre ami
notre ami Ali resa firousa qui alors
voilà bien sûr tu vas avoir les les
Noirs dans cette dans cette partie
puis il commence à leur rythme donc
c'est vrai que je la partie de jeu était
la dernière a commencé la dernière à
finir donc c'est normal ça va être la
dernière à recommencer et on voit une
pétrole de la part de notre de notre ami
Ali resa
ça fait plusieurs fois que on je lis que
ton sang est faible alors je sais pas si
c'est la vérité ou pas mais il y a des
petites chances et salut Doc people
mon micro est devant moi je suis à fond
j'ai pu oublier Monaco date de la
première pierre cramling qui est
l'inoxydable pliagramlink date de la
première olympiade de piagramink je vais
trouver Yoshua je vais trouver Yoshi
parce que je sais à peu près quel âge
elle a
dû commencer c'est très jeune je dirais
que c'était 1982
on en est où là
niveau histoire culture et chicken 1982
je tente
au pif hein
mais ouais je pense je pense que Pierre
est à peu près 55 ans
elle a dû être très très jeune dans
l'équipe
plus que ça
en 1982 tu crois qu'elle a joué non mais
en Ligue espagnole
et je l'avais battu et du coup bon ben
c'est une maison faut que vous avez
regardé un petit peu pour palmarès après
la partie et je sais plus ce que j'avais
vu mais
j'ai déjà vu ce truc là
1978 nous dit Paul qui est 1972 1978 bah
tu vois
c'est pas pas si loin quoi elle est née
en quoi pardon non non les premières
Olympiades ah oui en 1978 de la part de
Piaf et tu vois je l'ai j'avais vu
j'avais raison elle avait 15 ans donc
c'est en fait Yoshi sans nous dire son
âge
78 - 15 63 on est en 2023 a priori elle
a bien elle est bien
cette vitesse là
je fais gaffe les âges j'ai calcule vite
quand même
[Musique]
elle garde quand même une ouais elle a
pas
alors évidemment elle joue un peu moins
bien qu'avant mais je veux quand même
très très bien c'est ça qui est assez
incroyable mais que son style c'est pas
si étonnant c'est un style très très
positionnel très très calme et donc elle
fait toujours ça fait toujours des
merveilles
alors attends on est arrivé on est
arrivé il y a une il y a eu une chute
qui a été à jouer assez rapidement je
peux revenir un peu en arrière on arrive
ça c'est théorique ce truc là
mais ça ça a l'air d'aller complètement
pour les Noirs c'est une théorique mon
Collard il va pas il va falloir faire
mieux que ça pour revenir contre Ali
resa pour poser des problèmes à notre
ami
au génie au prodiges français à lire les
affaires rouge à
là on peut pas
ça ça se passe plutôt bien est-ce qu'on
va pas voir un petit peu Jul
tu vas aller voir
Jul et oui c'est vrai qu'elle est née
comme le King ah mais c'est facile à
retenir du coup
elle est née en avril 63 comme Gary
casparent évidemment qui a fêté ses 60
ans cette année tout à fait tout à fait
le King Guy
alors
la partie depuis le début si vous voulez
hein
un peu modeste mais qui qui se joue
parfaitement
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit Jules avant le
hier c'est Rohff qui change tout le
temps dans ces parties online donc c'est
très très compliqué de se préparer là on
voit j'imagine que la française était
une surprise
moi qui l'ai Ripeux 5 mais je pense pas
ah non non il y a encore bien préparé
alors évidemment il y a la paire de fou
pour les blancs mais légère avantage
développement chez les Noirs donc on
vise le long terme avec les Blancs
tandis qu'on vise le court terme avec
les Noirs voilà faut que je trouve un
coup dynamique ici peut-être Dame des
quatre évidemment je pense toujours
toujours le premier coup qui me vient
des quatre cahier des quatre pour
attaquer pour attaquer
tu vois ça que j'aurais pas fait de
manière naturelle tu vois mais parce que
si Dame prank et prend en fait ça coûte
dynamique parce que tu attaques une
autre pièce et si d'un prank avait les
prank tu attaque ces deux il faut que je
le fout des trois alors là déjà je peux
faire à mon avis le coup sera de faire
on va montrer tiens dame prend Caval
elle est propre parce que c'est
intéressant ça me prend ok
parce que c'est salé et si tu joues
petit rock qui est le coup naturel je
vais faire qui est B3
et je légalisé
voilà c'est ça exactement soit je te
ouais je te prends des œufs tu choisis
mais je te prends c'est sûr et là
évidemment la position est quand même
très très symétrique très très
équilibrée
donc c'est ça l'idée alors dame descart
je n'ai pas à cause de fou G5 il a joué
5 je m'enlève du
corps
et c'est pas grave
bien sûr si je mange le cavalier je
perds le fou le pion peut pas défendre
les deux cases en même temps
ok donc avec les jouets
ok
il y a quelque chose d'autre à faire
est-ce que tu as un problème déjà de
laisser
bon c'est inévitable hein je peux pas
trop l'empêcher mais ouais c'est ça
est-ce que est-ce que on va casser la
structure au noir on va donner la part
de faux pour ça
mais en terme de compensation qu'est-ce
qui se passe
il y a pas vraiment de compensation mais
c'est à dire que c'est pas si grave
parce que finalement ils sont pas facile
à attaquer ces pions et normalement ça
final de tour ça tient tous les 5 ouais
c'est 5 c'est ça
tu manges là je prends l'intermédiaire
ici
et je te crée aussi un plan isolé
exactement
ouais les noirs sont pas mal là
qui peut être intéressant mais en
général c'est dur c'est dur de croire
que les blancs vont avoir un vrai
avantage ici j'aime bien quand même
j'aime j'aime bien j'aime bien les
blancs parce que la structure quand même
je pense que
je pense qu'il y a moyen que je que je
termine un peu ah non mais ça c'est sûr
que les blancs sont un peu mieux ça
c'est pas bien même pas de question
donc
la ligne c'est vrai que bon même s'il y
a pas échec je crois que j'ai encore
faux E4 parce que non ça se regarde
quand même mais pour voir
malheureusement
qui doit regarder Jul
prend des trois et B3 échec surtout
reprendre
ce thème avec ce pion à trois finalement
qui est décidément très mal placé tu vas
avoir pu isoler ça va compenser ma
structure en plus tu as même pas pris un
rêve si ce pour l'instant
donc ça ça va aller pour les Noirs donc
j'ai l'impression que fou prend cavalier
prend et petit rock ça doit être la
ligne mais
comment on fait ici avec qu'est-ce que
ça donne cette histoire
ma lampe pas grand chose quand même pour
les pour les blancs
[Musique]
il faut le défendre et tours c'est
souvent des fourchettes avec les deux
donc c'est pas le cas pour l'instant
mais on voit que les pièces blanches
font du mal à bouger et il y a des
belles compensations pour le noir en
termes d'activité
c'est la partie qui est de 4
je pense qu'il faut manger quand même un
jour parce que tu as un problème sur le
plan C2 et sur l'activité je pense qu'il
faut un moment donné il faut essayer de
de casser la structure des Noirs surtout
qu'elle n'a plus la part de fou avec les
Blancs donc tu peux donner le fou quoi
sans problème là c'est très concret je
trouve parce que tu fais [__] puis on
prend
[Musique]
une bonne idée malheureusement il y a ça
je peux dire même manger je pense vous
montrer mais dans l'idée tour ici on va
attaquer ici deux fois non peut-être que
là je peux même jouer et je prie de
prise peut-être que ça peut en fait
tenir non mais là je prends
ça
la première idée c'est celle-là et en
fait là j'ai tourné deux et
malheureusement je peux pas faire à
cause du pion en deux et là je suis
complètement vissé parce que maintenant
doit rester là moi de rester là et cette
position si elle est nable franchement
c'est bravo tu as l'air durant
franchement
les noirs sont enfin je veux dire il y a
pas de il y a aucun risque pour les pour
les Noirs c'est sûr
après
non mais j'aurais fait plutôt j'aurais
pas fait en fin du coup j'aurais fait H4
H2O G3 ouais ouais on sait mais ok mais
ok évidemment c'est pas un truc qui se
regarde peu importe mais avec le pion en
F2 ça va parce que je fais roi F1 pour
là et roi E2 et la tour va partir mais
avec le pion en moins F3 finalement ça
c'est pas une bonne idée à cause du
planche à deux bon en tout cas on voit
qu'il y a plein de problèmes pratiques
qui peuvent arriver et c'est la partie
il a pas mangé F6
certainement bref ça voilà ça c'est un
mois donc faut 3 ok G4 que chose comme
ça
ah oui d'accord ah oui non mais d'accord
ah oui mais moi en fait j'aime pas les
blancs ah oui d'accord ok ok d'accord
oui non je crois qu'il faut qu'ils
mettent
là pour l'avantage
c'est pas très bien passé
et que peut-être nul c'est pas un
si mauvais choix ici
et salut à nos amis du chat là qui se
s’échange des amabilités c'est ça
ambiance dans le chat je n'aime frame ah
oui
[Musique]
arrête 18h25
franchement recharger on les connaît les
gens qui passent à raconter leur journée
chargée moi je les connais on fait pas
le coup moi aussi je me dis que j'ai des
jours à charger mais je passe ma journée
à dire j'ai une nouvelle chargée c'est
ça le truc
alors ouais je crois que Jules là il va
falloir qu'il mette un coup de frein à
main qu'est-ce qui pourquoi il réfléchit
sur ton chemin vite il y a pas eu droit
je ne dois rien réfléchi à d'où ça
tourne
est-ce que tour des si c'est
envisageable pour justement éviter ces
mais je vois pas trop l'intérêt
honnêtement
qui peut être pas mal mais ok
tu pousses un petit peu là
j'ai l'impression que ça fait quasiment
nul direct non
tu veux pas être moins bien que les
Blancs je trouve que non non mais en
fait je pense qu'il essaie de jouer une
position où il peut essayer peut-être à
un moment donné de garder rien du tout
je prends un M6 tu fais quoi toi
je planifie pas c'est ce que m'a dit il
y a comme une fois
c'est un peu moins bien il me dit oui
mais je planifie pas de la peine et
effectivement
en fait il y a des trucs comme ça ou
c'est vrai que allez symboliquement on
se dit allez les noirs sont un petit peu
mieux mais parce qu'ils ont déjà
initiative mais bon
si on joue des coups raisonnables avec
avec les avec les Blancs on va pas la
perdre
tu m'as déjà demandé
j'avance pas trop voilà yes Mama c'est
pas c'est pas terrible ça c'est truc
enfin j'ai des grands projets des grands
calendriers des grandes échéances
mais
pas
ça s'appelle la paresse voilà c'est
c'est aussi simple que ça tu sais que si
tu le fais pas chaque fois va te le on
va te le rappeler à chaque film ouais
mais je préfère ça que le faire en fait
non mais moi j'ai un contrat non mais
attends tu sais que j'ai fait je suis
obligé de le faire je vais le faire de
toute façon après je pense par période
des fois tu as plus envie de le faire
que d'autres plus de motivation disons
que j'ai non c'est pas c'est moins
d'anti enfin tu vois c'est pas c'est que
par période j'ai un peu moins moins
envie de le faire que d'habitude tu vois
en fait voilà
et surtout le texte en fait le texte en
anglais qui me l'a bien vendu en tout
cas
franchement mes fichiers et tout ça tout
est quasiment tout est prêt à 95% moi ce
qui me manque c'est le c'est le texte
les explications en anglais des
nouveautés franchement sur ce cours j'ai
plus de 105 j'ai plus de 100 nouveautés
c'est sûr ok après il y en a des plus ou
moins tu vois important ou pas mais j'ai
je ça sera un nouveau cours je fais
schnikov plus de 100 nouveautés lifetime
répertoire plus de 100 nouveautés ça
c'est sûr et avec quelques-unes qui sont
assez importantes pour Éline
donc ça c'est sûr mais le problème c'est
que le texte
expliquez chaque coup et c'est le truc
qui m'amuse pas pour être très honnête
je vous le dis voilà
faire les flèches et tout ça donner les
lignes ça m'amuse beaucoup mais faire le
texte
parfait non
combien de temps
à fond tous les jours
pas un mois et demi un mois de
c'est pas sympa de me paraître ça
franchement déprime
d'accord
[Musique]
ce qui se passe un peu chez les autres
bah tiens on voit les raisins il a il a
un an pardon ça c'est une autre partie
c'est dur de croire qu'il va se passer
quelque chose
qui a l'air gagnant je le vois pas du
tout la genou je vois une position je me
dis tiens et elle a gagné
je l'achète direct
sans nouveauté et sa ns tu es cruel tu
cruelle ouais Magnus il comprend un peu
le français ouais tout à fait il a vécu
en Belgique quand il était gamin alors
j'ai des notions de norvégien on peut
pas appeler ça des notions
je connais
je connais des je connais quelques mots
mais
j'ai allé 5 ans de mots de vocabulaire
pense pas qu'on puisse parler de notion
c'est dur hein
j'entends même pas l'oreille
salut Andy caisse
le texte ça se fait que j'ai pété à
chaque coup de le faire le temps
est-ce qu'il s'en sort ouais c'était sa
Pétrof où il s'en sortait oui oui il est
mieux allez
est-ce qu'il met la pression à les
raisins
et pourquoi donc c'est moi ou c'est mes
écouteurs
[Musique]
nous dire un peu ce qui se passe est-ce
que vous entendez Laurent j'ai un
problème de
je crois que j'ai mes écouteurs
à Tourcoing E4 et là je vous remets le
petit vient
en F6 ou cavalage 5
pour enlever la menace de matte du
couloir et après bah écoute il y a plein
de coups et j'ai envie de dire que en
pratique c'est hyper dur quand même
une belle coupe de cheveux
[Musique]
au tournoi chargeur
tu sais qu'il y a le il y a le
groupement chargé qui se joue mais bon
il est quelle heure vous êtes chez lui
il est pas dans un hôtel ah non mais je
suis pas d'Open comme ça honnêtement
je crois que j'ai vu des joueurs qui
participaient alors après c'est pas
pareil division 2 ou division 3 je suis
sûr qu'il y a des joueurs qui sont à
charge hein mais mais je crois pas la
division 1 c'est quand même très sérieux
je crois qu'il y a yo Yang
j'en avais vu plusieurs je crois qu'ils
font les deux mais ouais après les
horaires il faut il faut se débrouiller
parce que je sais pas ça joue le matin
maintenant on voit d'accord
sur le zoom ils font que de sortir c'est
un supportable
je vais essayer de vous remettre à
l'IRESA en caméra
malheureusement je ne contrôle pas les
joueurs qui quittent la salle et Jul a
fait nul dans la deuxième partie comme
on s'y attendait il y a une répétition
de coups
dès qu'on est parti donc on aura la
troisième partie attention un nuit 0,5
pour Abdou ça te ref pour l'instant qui
est tout en contrôle dans ce match il y
a pas de boulot encore deux parties du
coup donc
il y a moyen de refaire mais il faut pas
perdre la prochaine si il part la
prochaine ça sera terminé
et on l'avait vu ça non même quand il
mène et il joue normalement avec les
Blancs donc ça peut évidemment c'est
plus dangereux parce que on peut perdre
la troisième mais de l'autre côté on
peut aussi on a plus de chance de se
refaire face à un joueur qui va pas
forcément jouer super solide
et on voit aussi que le carwana a fait
match nul contre shimanov dans la
deuxième partie aussi
donc kervanahil dans le même
même scénario que pour cette horreur
avec un et demi sur deux et une victoire
de partie qui arrive leur permettrait de
ce qualifier pour la rendre suivante
pour les demi-finales
de cette poule cette première poule vous
savez que pour pour gagner le tournoi
enfin pour être éliminé pardon plutôt il
faut perdre deux matchs donc pour
l'instant
imaginons un si un joueur qui perd
aujourd'hui il aura encore une chance de
repasser via la poule des perdants
c'était le cas de manuscrit
contre eux
qu'il a perdu
je suis en train de réfléchir mais je
non
je me souviens pas
que ça soit qualifié
c'est plus honnêtement mais après il a
reperdu contre
le deuxième match il a perdu contre
la cas
entre Nakamura c'était un match où
contre un féminin il a perdu à la
surprise générale artemief le premier
match qui jouait très lentement il y a
eu quatre
quatre victoires noires je crois c'est
un match très bizarre attention à lire
j'aime pas du tout ce que fait notre ami
Ali Reza il dit que il perd une pièce
tout simplement ça
marche
peut-être
alors je sais pas mais alors ça ça
ouais bah c'est fini
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
on parlait du fait que on pensait que il
y a du raisin elle est allé gagner assez
facile ce matin
seulement 1 1
donc rien n'est fait il y a deux il y a
deux pions bon c'est c'est objectivement
complètement foutu mais bon il reste une
micro chance pratique
j'y crois pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est pas beaucoup
c'est la carte
ça a pas mal de prendre un set
h j'aime bien les petits coups
ok on a un petit décalage par rapport au
chaton souvent un petit peu en décalage
parce que voilà toujours c'est un souci
de
d'équité entre les joueurs et donc il y
a pas de triche il y a des contrôles et
un léger décalage dans les parties
quand vous écrivez un message sur le
chat nous on le voit une minute après
que vous l'avez écrit
donc
c'est pas ça on le voit en fait ils nous
entendent
avec une nuit de retard donc en fait
quand ils écrivent ils nous écrivent et
en fait il nous écrivent une minute
quand on était en train de parler il y a
une minute
on les voit de manière automatique mais
vous entendrez une minute après
et ça
c'est pour ça qu'on est long à la
détente pas que pour ça mais ça
participe à ça
ça explique aussi
pas facile de rester en contact avec
avec n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas quand
même mais bon restez en tout cas tu
donnes des questions si vous avez
aussi vous êtes sûr de plein de choses
par exemple tout à l'heure on parlait de
fameux vidéo qui allait sortir si vous
avez des questions en tout cas vous
savez que Laurent adore parler de ça
n'hésitez pas à solliciter il répondra
avec grand plaisir c'est dommage que le
site chasserole est fermé quand même
c'est moche et oui
non
parce que il y a un truc que je vous
garantis en tout cas la qualité du
produit est très
surveillé et donc il y a même un panel
qui teste les
vidéos avant que ça soit alors que ce
soit publié donc qui regarde tout ça
voilà des joueurs un peu tous les
niveaux de débutants à joueur confirmé
voilà pour pour dire si ça va ou ça va
pas donc le le processus de confection
de ces vidéos cheesebub c'est
courtschable de ce live time répertoire
chez sebbel et quand même
[Musique]
et quand même très très au point
clairement est-ce que tu aurais fait mon
petit coup
Laurent je suis sûr que oui
il prend les petits pions et bon bah tu
sais jouer c'est vu si c'est si c'est vu
c'est joué
c'est vrai que ça a l'air ouais en fait
tu peux pas créer une menace vraiment
c'est tellement foutu alors je crois que
je sais kiffer
je crois que je sais qui c'est est-ce
que tu connais toi non tu connais pas
est-ce que tu sais 125 tu es bien celui
que je connais
celui qui vient de faire une norme de
mètres
je suis désolé salut Jenny beno salut
Charles des webs joue 99 je plaisantais
je plaisantais Chelsea est très ouvert
et ça marche toujours aussi bien
évidemment très très beau site
tu peux
donc
on en est où pour l'instant les je crois
que les vidéos de chaise 24 restent
quand même complètement accessible au
moment où premium
donc je sais pas moi je suis pas dans le
processus
décisionnel donc si tu veux ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé pour les on va
rappeler peut-être qu'il y a des en tout
cas il y a dans moi qui est membre
Premium
et donc effectivement on maintenant on
décourage les gens de prendre des
abonnements premium n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à clé.com évidemment mais en
tout cas pour ceux qui restent qui avait
pris je sais pas il y en a qui avait
pris 10 ans parfois d'abonnement premium
pour l'instant les vidéos restent
complètement accessibles c'est sûr que
ce contenu ne disparaîtra pas du jour au
lendemain donc voilà
soit il sera sur je sais pas quelle
solution va être trouvé c'est pas du
tout
on n'est pas du tout dans l'organigramme
décisionnel mais en tout cas c'est cette
ce problème et clairement
[Musique]
ils ont clairement conscience de ce
problème
bon c'est fini il a abandonné
donc je vous donne un petit peu un petit
récap donc jus la pénurie contre contre
sa pièce
Nakamura et ben c'est venger sur sur One
forest donc égalise au score aussi
tandis que carvana a fait match nul
contre shimanov donc pour l'instant on a
un et demi sur deux Jules qui a 0,5 qui
va devoir essayer de revenir au score
dans la prochaine partie on a aussi un
partout entre filles rouge et ecolars on
a un partout chez Nakamura et vanpro est
et un et demi sur deux pour Caravana
contre 0,5
voilà voilà ça nous promet des 3e et
quatrième partie très excitante Stéphane
je crois bien on espère en tout cas on
reste on reste ensemble les petites pubs
à passer je suppose comme d'hab
comme d'habitude et nous il me répond
attention 25 qui a fait un stage on m'a
dit catastrophique enfin je me comprends
ouais il a été stagiaire quelque part
c'était catastrophique ils ont gardé un
souvenir enfin bon bref non je plaisante
évidemment 25
mais oui 25 oui d'accord ok allez on
fait le petit
ring tu passes un sinon je le fais moi
j'avais deux avant dans la maison
qualité de l'air on dort bien on
travaille bien on mange bien
yes elle a tout de suite tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour avec Laurent pour
la troisième ronde de cette première
phase de quart de finale
avec ici on va vous montrer la partie
entre furuza et Colars donc perdre avec
les avec les noirs et qui va avoir à
cœur je pense de
reprendre l'avantage ici donc il y a 1 1
dans ta vie
catalan qu'on a l'habitude de voir
maintenant très très agressif alors
aussi ça peut être ça peut être connecté
plus tard avec t-roc on peut on a le
on se laisse le choix mais ça peut être
évidemment connecté avec des kg 5
parfois pour des attaques assez brutales
donc très intéressant ce que fait Ali
resa et bon c'est vrai qu'il a gagné à
cette première partie dans la Catalane
il répète pas de surprise ici et fou B7
ouais clairement qui prépare la poussée
C5 en cas d'attaque elle a le droit
alors E4 c'est la réaction généralement
avant que nous on arrive à le C5
[Musique]
est-ce que tu es obligé de manger ou pas
tu es jamais obligé
quand même ouais parce que
j'arrive pas à comprendre qu'est-ce
qu'il veut faire sur pion prend le 4
il va faire cavaler les prank et j'ai 5
si j'ai l'impression que c'est ça qui
est pas mal non
cavaliers j'imagine ouais parce que
surtout prends il y aura un problème je
pense archi concret G5 qui gagne une
pièce je pense j'ai 5 on a on a hengé 5
qui renouvelle la menace de maths à H7
et le four en B7 reste toujours en l'air
bon ça évidemment Collard il va pas
tomber dans le piège là donc du coup
c'est quoi l'idée
mais bon c'est ça l'a un peu bizarre sur
quasiment
il est c'est un joueur qui risque
beaucoup
[Musique]
de risques dans cette partie de manière
générale
donc pas très intéressant à avoir joué à
chaque fois ça c'est une évidence et
regardez on va aller voir vite ce qui se
passe chez chez Jules parce que là j'ai
l'impression qu'elle nous attend il est
en train de me faire mentir et on avait
prévu on se mettait Jules avec les on se
mettait Jules avec les Noirs il a les
noirs
assez connue je pense de la de la Vienna
ou du Corps Malade accepté c'est une ah
non c'est une anti-tarache ok je peux
vous montrer
ça reste quand même très très solide et
là de la soda 2 est clairement ouais
quelque chose d'assez connu pour forcer
plus ou moins la nul après dame 5 d'amd6
ouais c'est jouer Dame des 6 et bah d'où
ça te va certainement se contenter d'une
nul ici
OK puis nul c'est un bon résultat parce
que effectivement ça lui fait dehors
et ça veut dire que Jules doit gagner
non seulement la dernière mais en plus
l'armée donc qui qui suivrait en cas de
victoire dans la dernière
partie bonus avec pour rester de gagner
avec les Blancs derrière
parce que quand elle est longue dans un
truc comme ça mais essayer de
la pression et de gagner directement le
match
il y a pas de choix d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il avait fait il avait
continué tant bon matin
Joachim Mohamed ah salut c'est bien un
petit peu ton droit de mettre Florent
aussi
[Musique]
alors
bon c'est tout à fait normal peut-être
fou des 6 on va essayer de changer les
fous normalement avec les noix est-ce
qu'on fait fou aussi si si ou pas on a
allégé déficit structurel mais ça permet
quand même de relâcher un petit peu la
tension
et donc en général c'est pas très grave
d'avoir ce pion aussi un petit peu un
petit peu faible parce que on a du mal à
attaquer avec les Blancs
mais est-ce qu'il va vraiment faire ça
Jules où il va commencer par fousser 5
comme ça je j'en sais rien honnêtement
c'est simple peut paraître intéressant
pour essayer de des logiciels
un temps sur la tour et en plus qui peut
menacer des trucs sur F2 donc
humainement par envie de commencer
parfois les cinq j'ai envie de dire
général et maintenant voir on peut faire
faux aussi
encore plus solide tout à fait donc
et je fouette
il y avait pas besoin de s'enflammer
avec vous aussi soit aussi c'était trop
solide alors on dit que mon fond n'est
pas bon alors
c'est vrai qu'en plus on a on a un délai
on a un délai d'une minute par rapport à
vous donc ouais mais là ton sang enfin
vraiment
je t'entends très bien
pendant la pause et ben ça fait des
trucs sur mon sur mon sur mon bureau et
j'ai éloigné un peu le micro et quand
j'ai vu le message de ciel bleu et ben
j'ai accroché mon micro et donc on sait
pas moi je sais pas si depuis que je
l'ai rapproché il y a une minute est-ce
que mon son est un peu mieux maintenant
où est-ce que vraiment je dois faire un
truc mais là je pense que normalement à
mon sens il est plutôt OK
quoi ok bon en tout cas faut F5 qui a
été joué donc c'est une position qui a
l'air assez égale en tout cas ah ouais
ça c'est moins qu'on puisse dire est-ce
que
vrai
essayez de prendre le contrôle de la
colonne D et la case D5 notamment est-ce
que je peux pas essayer de prendre un
petit avantage
je crois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui s'il y
a quelqu'un qui joue pour quelque chose
ici c'est quand même les blancs
mais ça peut être évident ouais c'est
peut-être tu vois y réfléchit un peu qui
peut te poser une question déjà ouais
mais je vais en E1 et là tu veux faire
tourner vite c'est ça
ouais en fait je veux dire une tour pour
pour faire ça mais
nul
mais peut-être rien c'est pas le mieux
même si ça a l'air cool logique
mais ouais c'est dur en tout cas de
faire quelque chose avec les Blancs
il a tellement pas joué pour faire
quelque chose que
c'est pas maintenant s'il fallait faire
quelque chose c'était avant mais bon en
même temps il a une micro chance de de
pousser gentiment comme on dit donc
pourquoi pas il réfléchit un petit peu
après le problème de A6 à 4 c'est quand
même une inclusion qui est favorable au
noir parce qu'il y a la caisse B4 il y a
peu peur des fous B4 qui arrive le pur à
4 peut être fait dans certains cas mais
alors ça paraît très lointain il y a pas
de kb5 enfin voilà ah six à 4 et quand
même une inclusion très favorable cahier
des 5 j'avais pensé parce que sur quel
écran il a tout reprend on perd une
pièce c'est aussi simple mais j'ai
l'impression que cavalier 4 est pas mal
hein
intéressant en tout cas
attention à la fourchette quand même
allez
donc faut faire on peut pas faire
complètement tout ce qu'on veut
[Rires]
on va te faire les poches ça continue
après après tu vois en authentique
c'est-à-dire que on commence sans
ordinateur et c'est vrai que bon ben on
blender
c'est mieux de faire grandir parce que
mettre l'ordi et cliquer enfin c'est
juste c'est juste tellement facile en
fait et je pense que si vous n'avez pas
sur le site pour voir un peu comment
nous on réfléchit comment nous on voit
les choses et si on est là pour vous
lire l'ordinateur en fait juste il y a
il y a aucun intérêt quoi
donc je me suis dit après avoir blender
mais c'est vrai tu vois c'est ça reste
humain donc ça c'est c'est
bien alors
vas-y on va regarder j'abandonne pas
aussi vite moi tu sais
quand même pour C8
j'arrivais en fait parce qu'on on quand
même
alors effectivement mais pas l'ordi mais
on bouge les pièces donc ce qui est un
gros avantage par rapport aux joueurs
évidemment vous le savez on bouge la
pièce on voit la jauge donc c'est vrai
que c'est ça fait quand même beaucoup
mon cavalier
5 qui perd instant
et pour 8 ce que la question je me
posais c'est est-ce que tout rond
comment ça marche tout A1
est-ce que vous prend F2 j'arrive pas à
calculer
ce truc vous prend F2 qui gagne pour
prendre cavalier prendre tu prends 8
mais faut prendre F5 c'est terminé non
donc
ouais d'accord mais ce que je veux dire
c'est au moins deux pièces en fait c'est
blanc qui pousse quand je dis c'est
terminé
en 4 il prend tout son sens avec les
pions B7 qui qui sont fixés qui vont
être mangé sur le long terme
donc en fait cette ligne elle est pas si
simple après on a raté un truc quelque
part
c'est 8 on avait dit quoi [__]
peut-être que j'ai mieux peut-être qu'il
faut j'essaie de sortir de cette
de cette de ce clouage
comment est-ce que je peux sortir un
cavalier 3 peut-être
je fais un peu le freestyle
mais sur ça les cavaliers 7 je m'en fous
qui qui
mais bon peut-être c'est juste le coup
ça va marcher ça va marcher et si je
bouge ma tour je retourne
les trois quand même te reprends le 2 il
y a que camaïeu de minimum ouais et bref
4 et
non parce que
il y a toujours il y a le fou tout
simplement
je prends ici
oui alors
non
ce que tu as proposé
à ça et tu bouges le roi là je mange F5
est-ce que tu manges là je mange là et
là on est comme tout à l'heure où je
déplace pour la Torah ouais là c'est
bien pour les blancs non mais je suis
d'accord que j'ai 3 et un super coup moi
j'ai pas du tout vu
j'ai pas du tout vu que j'ai 3 donc
c'est un très bon coup je regardais tout
8 donc pour C8
on a une minute de délai donc oui c'est
ça
ouais donc et c'est jouer ton C8 c'est
la partie
d'accord on s'en fout des trois c'est
que j'ai trois solutions ça c'est sûr
S
[Musique]
ok bon bref on va le laisser réfléchir
j'ai tout alors vas-y une autre idée
aussi je pense que ça ça tient aussi
pour les pour les Noirs c'est de contre
attaquer le coup de Fischer
je crois que ça marche aussi
parce que si tu prends bêtement deux
fois 4 mais je prends en dessin qui est
tout va bien
faut encore répondre à une petite
question sur le clouage mais je vais
jouer ton CD8 en fait je vais menacer
mate du couloir et je me décloue et tout
va bien
en tout cas c'était c'est égal on pense
mais il y a un gros bordel de pièces au
milieu et il peut se passer plein de
choses
tout à fait alors retour assez vite
c'est la partie ils sont quand même en
contrôle niveau tactique oui non non ça
calcule bien quand même je pense il peut
se passer
c'est ça on sent pas que il n'y a pas un
qui va faire une pièce quoi disons que
c'est moi qui dois partir il y a une
chance sur deux que je perde que je
perds dans les 5 prochaines
[Musique]
en ce moment ça fait peur
c'est vrai ça fait peur attention pour
l'instant c'est les Noirs clairement ce
que tu as dit là qui va les prendre F2
pareil et il y a le problème de poids de
plus précis et elle fout ces quatre qui
ont qui en l'air comme on dit il est pas
il est pas protégé
vraiment au temps il est moins bien au
temps ça fait plaisir pour Jules s'il
pouvait
ça va être dur quand même si vous pouvez
faire quelque chose j'allais dire mais
bon
la compétition pourquoi tu joues pas
compétition Laura j'essaie de me
qualifier au playing alors il m'est
arrivé déjà j'ai fait un forfait un
forfait j'étais inactif forcément
j'ai perdu le match pour arriver en
division 3 tu sais moi c'est pas
division 1 je joue la division 3 mais à
la limite j'ai joué une rente de plus
peut-être que j'aurais pu arriver en
division de enfin en tout cas si je
gagnais la ronde que j'ai pas joué donc
j'ai pas été à Paris je jouais pour être
en Division 2
mais voilà c'était pas
c'était j'apprends j'apprends le tournoi
à l'autre si on part plus de 5 minutes
faut refresh pour pas être inactif c'est
ça le truc c'est pas mal mais d'un côté
c'est aussi assez sévère parce que tu
fais tu prends une pause enfin voilà
quoi tiens c'est la partie mais en plus
je veux dire il y a une pause après la
rendre 7 qui est de officiellement de
six minutes tu vois donc en vrai
tu vois en fait tu t'en vas six minutes
fais un peu plus toujours parce que tu
es jamais complètement le dernier à
finir bah c'est normal d'être inactif
pendant 5 minutes mais c'est vrai que
j'avais pas un coup de F5 tu vois et un
coup de F5 sur l'ordi sur un coup de F5
et c'était bon j'étais à Paris à la
ronde d'après donc c'était un peu
rageant
ça m'a un peu agacé j'ai perdu ce match
j'ai perdu ce match il a très bien joué
c'est shigaf là d'ailleurs il jouait la
Division 3
il a fait 100 matchs de plus dans la
première quand même mais bon
c'est un peu dommage mais en fin de
journée comme ça je sais que c'est dur
parce que c'est long c'est tournoi mine
de rien neuf rondes
en 10 + 2
c'est quand même
c'est quand même 5 heures de jeu tu vois
c'est beaucoup de notes beaucoup de
choses qui se passent des déconnexions
sans faire exprès
c'est quand même c'est un vrai tournoi
c'est pas c'est pas de la rigolade en
tout cas c'est le qualifié un jour on
ira te casse un petit peu là
le poulailler la division 3 ah oui là
pour l'instant la division 2 et 3 je les
ai pas ouverte sur zoom mais t'inquiète
pas que le jour où tu y es je vais voir
ce qui se passe au poulailler oh là là
j'aimerais bien non mais franchement
mais la dernière fois j'ai il se trouve
que en fait la le niveau du tournoi
était bien moins fort que d'habitude la
dernière fois parce que il se trouve que
des autres tournois en même temps il y
avait pour voilà ce tournoi de
mais ce tournoi final il y a le grand
Chester en même temps donc ça enlève
quand même ça enlève 10 joueurs qui
jouent en ce moment à Varsovie qui sont
quand même qui sont sur se qualifier on
va pas se mentir donc ça fait en gros ça
fait 10 places en plus enfin tu vois
c'est quand même c'est quand même énorme
et toi comme ça
et donc là on a des échanges généralisés
ouais là il se passe pas grand chose ça
va très certainement faire nul est-ce
qu'on va voir
un petit peu notre notre frère
il est complètement capable de faire ce
genre de courant qui sont vraiment très
très
[Musique]
osé hein donc il a fait que j'ai 5 ans
on avait dit que cavalier prend un
quatre est un petit peu chaud à cause de
C5
et même on va allier un petit peu toutes
les ou des cinq
toutes les idées que tu avais proposé à
un prise prise avec avec rang rock suivi
de cavaliers prend le 4 alors là du coup
on a des des vis-à-vis ici ici et c'est
ultra chaud franchement il peut bien
calculer parce que tu es pas à l'abri de
te prendre une tactique
honnêtement j'avais pas vu la jauge mais
au feeling
ça a l'air quand même au dangereux c'est
l'air trop dangereux pour les Noirs
simplement après je peux faire trois
chemin
est-ce que tu reprends des 7 marche pas
là donc sur cavalier
ce matin on peut le montrer d'ailleurs
c'est joli
c'est pas mon problème c'est toi qui est
noire merci
je mange de montrer qu'elle prend des
scènes ici c'est vous voyez ce petit on
va montrer dame prend aussi son attaque
la dame franchement
c'est pareil j'ai mis le défenseur F6 et
en plus je fais échec et je me place au
prochain
et sur cavaler prend des stand on a vu
et surtout prenez soin c'est la même
chose suivi de et attention que sur
cavalier prend des 7 je joue pas
cavalier
prend le retour et je défends H7 donc
voilà c'est pas possible tout ça
[Musique]
franchement ça a l'air de raser mais
bon
en pratique c'est extrêmement dur pour
pour le noir j'ai l'impression ouais
mais il joue vite regarde il a 4 minutes
d'avance la jauge elle a l'air de dire
que finalement c'est pas si mal
il faut il faut terminer le job là j'en
ai marre
mais je vais venir normalement mon 1500
hello je le joue le 16 juin
16 juin
[Musique]
les cathédrales de France et de Navarre
je pensais jouer à 1500 et là j'ai vu
que pour l'instant si jamais je
voulais demain je veux un 767 j'ai vu oh
là là là du coup ça change de niveau ah
oui
il se passe plein de choses on va voir
ce qui s'est passé
de partout ah non
je prends ici c'est toi
mais ça ça a l'air complètement foutu il
faut prendre un filtre le fou défend
ben alors mon petit allié raisin
je sais pas en fait tu fais un autre
truc
pas vu non je sais pas
tu recules mais bon quand même
là ça a l'air complètement et en fait
c'est ça le problème j'ai pas vu un truc
hein
OK
pour deux pièces et que les pièces qui
sont un petit peu les organisés je te
dois attaque sur la colonne âge un
ouais pour recette c'est pas ouf j'ai 7
est-ce que tu préfères
pas du tout j'essaie de tourner 8 3 7
puis on prend G6 et ça y est on revient
dans la zone où c'est dans le
eux
défendre sur la 8e rangée genre si je
pouvais faire ça ça et ça ce serait
terminé
qui a validé 3 qui peut arriver derrière
alors
je garde un œil
c'est sûr
parce qu'il souffre un petit peu là il
s'est mis à temps qu'il lâche rien
ouzbek là
le petit
qui est très chiant qui défend tout il
prend
qui contrôle l'eldame et l'ailer le roi
en même temps et en général ouais
clairement comment est-ce qu'on va
réussir à s'en sortir après c'est un
pion un avec une tour cavalier donc
c'est c'est pas encore même super le
pion
j'ai envie de dire que c'est pas encore
à la fin du monde je pense que ça reste
encore jouable mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand même une mauvaise nouvelle parce
que là quand tu es mené un et demi tu
sais que tu perds celle-là tu perds le
match
c'est pas simplement c'est pas marrant
et il va mettre la tour derrière
qu'est-ce que tu veux tout à trois tours
à deux c'est de s'activer comme ça
mais effectivement c'est nul
objectivement ça c'est à peu près
des problèmes qui va quand même
il va essayer de poser des problèmes au
maximum
quand tu l'as dit la situation idéale
pour lui ah oui bah
il joue il sait que bah si tiens bah ok
il y a encore une autre partie et puis
s'il gagne c'est fini quoi et
pour deux résultats il y a pas de risque
alors que alors que Jules
toi absolument la tenir ça c'est
obligatoire
allez mon petit Jules après il a le bon
coup il a [__] case noire quand même
enfin c'est le fou
qui est plus le Fou est quand même
globalement quoi que ça joue sur une
seule
maintenant qu'il est en F6 il est pas
terrible
mais bon il pouvait pas rester
à deux qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il fasse
ça ça et puis activer un peu le roi
aussi peut-être
il est impressionnant il est
impressionnant pour l'instant il nous
fait un sans faute
vas-y donne moi un coup douteux qu'il a
joué
j'en vois pas un perso
c'est dur quand même de voir comment il
va progresser avec les blancs
mais après bon bah écoute si tu me
laisses monter le roi ben je vais monter
le roi et puis là ça va être plus simple
donc là c'est que la tour camel est
importante ici
je pense pas qu'on a envie de le laisser
passer le roi sans que ça sortait trois
cavaler ses 6 ben les blancs pourraient
presque menacer un coup comme roi des
droits donc pour l'instant non parce
qu'il y a une découverte mais c'est vrai
que ramener le roi c'est
une bonne chose pour les blancs ça
serait même critique
quasi synonyme de victoire c'est ça que
si on le met en B5 au lieu de mettre en
E2 bon allez les noirs sont foutus tout
simplement
en finale il faut monter le roi c'est
important dans le chat il y a plein de
gens qui qui n'y pensent pas en finale
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec Laurent laisse
pas à la maison on le voit on va le on
va l'amener en jeu parce qu'au final
c'est une pièce quoi et si vous le
bougez pas vous êtes en sous-effectif
par rapport à l'adversaire c'est
vraiment important de monter le roi à
chaque fois en finale dès que le roi en
fait n'est plus en danger d'être mat ou
quoi que ce soit et ben il faut le
monter en finale
tout à fait et en plus là il pourrait
soutenir il a vraiment alors il est très
actif c'est une pièce il peut soutenir
et puis on passait ou alors parfois le
roi il peut aller manger d'autres pions
enfin voilà quand il a une vraie cible
c'est encore
c'est ça encore mieux mais là
effectivement s'il peut aller en P5 là
c'est clairement ça casse hein la casse
B5 en soutien du pion a parce qu'on voit
quand même avec le cavalier cette tour
il faut non seulement le protéger ce
Piona mais en plus il faut il faut
essayer de l'accompagner de de pousser
dans ces pas simple parce que il y a la
tour qui protège il y a la cavaliers qui
attaque qui attaque la Casa 6 et donc en
menace de pousser mais pas vraiment on
savait qu'avec le roi dans le cou ça
serait quand même beaucoup beaucoup plus
simple
est-ce qu'un plan comme pour B5 avec des
cavaliers C6 et je pense même à tout en
B6
et le pion plus long possible
et le Caval est là
d'après les Noirs ils vont jouer hein
ça c'est sûr même si c'était pas mal
avec les Noirs c'est pas facile avec le
long avant de trouver ça
bah je sais pas le planter tu es pas mal
moi je trouve ouais mais bon j'imagine
que c'est non quoi enfin j'ai le temps
de venir
mais bon
H4 d'abord pour avoir une seule
faiblesse à Leroy le pion F2
avec mon petit pion en H4 H3 avec les
Noirs ça aurait pu être ouais
donc c'est bien de fixer
donc
je t'encaisse
je t'encaisse la famille F2 j'ai trois
H4 tu peux manger tout le monde donc il
va pas faire ça a priori ça m'étonnerait
en tout cas
il y a toujours fou hein qui est une
menace parce que ok il s'organise comme
ça
pas pouvoir venir se rapprocher de ses
pions
c'est gagnant je pense pas que ce soit
gagnant non là je pense que justement
avant peut-être mais à un moment la
chose je vais le montrer vraiment un bel
avantage il va refaire
celui de pas terrible
franchement
j'ai pas ça a été gagné en Provence
toujours nul mais bon ok maintenant je
pense que c'est vraiment complètement
dur en fait
comment tu fais je crois même pas de
coup en fait pour empêcher de
par contre c'est chaud
donc ça c'est pas possible en fait c'est
le pion est pas vrai en plus
c'est une erreur apparemment oh là là
merci il aurait fallu faire à la place
un tour peut-être
manger F2 c'est la partie
un petit peu
[Musique]
ce que quelque chose comme ça
je vais essayer de remettre oh là là
salut mon cher Pro Évolution échec qui
va te rejoindre un de ces jours je sais
pas exactement quel jour il doit en
savoir plus notre ami Kevin thérieux qui
viendra commenter avec toi je ne serai
là
les deux premières journées ensuite
le supplice va commencer pour toi
Stéphane
tu vas commencer avec Kevin bon il faut
se sacrifier la bonne cause
la bonne c'est ta mère de l'année et oui
bravo
en tout cas n'hésitez pas à aller voir
non mais en plaisant très très bon
entraîneur
[Musique]
son site Pro Évolution échec où il y a
des cours pour tout niveau
et surtout
[Musique]
joueur
joueur débutant joueur pas hyper
confirmé voilà c'est ça là la cible si
je sais pas peut-être je dis des bêtises
tu le présenteras mieux que moi
j'ai l'impression que son site est fait
pour les joueurs jusqu'à 1800 voilà
ouais ouais je pense à 1800 je pense à
peu près
la reine
ok ben tu auras à tourner vite ça va
gagner non
craqué là mais bon il met tellement la
pression Abdou sa torov il est tellement
précis
é
bon je crois qu'il va pas venir notre
ami
parce que franchement il était pas loin
du tout de tenir cette finale
il va abandonné après tu auras 4 je
pense pas qu'il va continuer
parce que même s'il arrive à GF1 F4 le
jour il mangera là il perdra aussi être
4 et le problème c'est que le roi est
trop proche
de moi une tour c'est beaucoup
donc Jules probablement éliminé par
éliminer éliminer de la poule des
gagnants mais il va falloir qu'on
apparaison demain dans la poule
déperdant donc il va probablement
affronter alors j'ai le bracket juste là
je peux vous le montrer si vous voulez
attends je l'ai
que je n'ai pas là je pense
attends je l'ai ici mais il va
probablement affronter
[Musique]
il y a plus droit à l'erreur shimanov
c'est quand même qualifié donc attention
ouais
qui a perdu
dans la partie en plus
il a mangé le pion L7 il a quand même
pas mal de pions
en fait
il s'est pris un matin un coup à
l'heure qu'il était à + 3 sur mon
ordinateur
d'un F5
il y a un problème sur la tour
et je menace de manger ici et si tu fais
roi F7 et ben je te reprends assez
simplement
et surtout reprend
apparemment ça gagne
on est bien et au lieu de faire la F5
qui gagne la partie et ben il s'est pris
un matin un coup il a fait dame D3 et
ses prix
tu sais à quoi ça ressemble
à
oui d'amener 3 ne menace absolument rien
ouais ça peut être un c'est clair ça a
l'air
la souris s'est arrêtée
donc ça peut être ça peut être les deux
ça peut être les deux
donc déjà on voit on voit que alors je
donne les résultats carwana qui a
éliminé si maintenant avec deux et demi
Nakamura qui a fait match nul contre
donc il va y avoir une quatrième partie
entre Nakamura et Van forest
donc on a aussi une quatrième partie
d'ailleurs avec firouzja et ecolar 5 qui
est mené maintenant 2-1 entre amis qui
roule et Jules malheureusement qui s'est
fait éliminé par par amsaturh mais Jules
qui va revenir demain et qui va jouer il
va venir là il va venir il m'envoie un
message il faut passer vite cool alors
vas-y pendant la pause peut-être tu peux
le bah écoute l'intégrer on intègre et
puis et puis on revient dans 5 minutes
avec Jules du coup à tout de suite
[Musique]
il faut qu'il m'accepte il m'a pas
accepté encore
non
demande d'amis envoyer
si vraiment je peux l'envoyer un mythe
mais je préférerais pas toujours mise
avec partage d'écran et tout là ça
risque de me faire bugger
parce que je l'appelle ta caméra
en fait
[Musique]
je te rappelle OK
ça va
il a pas ah ça y est
attendez je dois régler caméra du coup
ça marche
c'est vraiment un coup là
je mets vos caméras là
si vous voulez si vous voulez passer de
votre tête tu peux nous expliquer un
petit peu vu ce que tu as
ce que tu penses avoir raté enfin tout
ce que tu viens de dire à Laurent je
vais me le répéter non non
on va on va repasser là avec toi déjà
et là j'étais en pause là ouais
oui là mais j'avais mis la pause et
pendant ce temps-là j'aurais réglé là
j'ai réglé les trucs allez bah c'était
chaud par contre si je mets ta caméra on
va pas aller chez qui
parce que j'ai mis la butée alors
l'autre début ce que je peux faire une
rapide
ah mais sinon j'enlève ma caméra je vous
mets tous les deux
je vais faire ça je vais prendre une vue
débile je vais prendre genre de Forest
Naka dans sa chambre encore je vais
prendre
[Musique]
ouais en fait ce que je vais faire c'est
que je
attends
ah oui
pour une minute je vais je vais faire un
truc malin
et je vais enlever
Abdou son hop
et
c'est ça et hop
si j'avais le tableau donc c'est pas mal
enfin il est fort mais ça va quoi
[Musique]
ok oui j'avais deux caméras avec Jules
ok bah écoute on va partir sur la
première vue après on va mettre
on va présenter déjà tu connais mais hop
et on est bon à 3 2 1
[Musique]
non en fait tout fait nul faut juste que
je reste oui c'est ça
qui est bien c'est tout à 5 et 3 D8 ou
non en fait
était défendue par j'ai joué trop vite
je te dis je me suis complètement
déconcentré et je pensais qu'il voulait
tout reprendre F2 tours on va on va
montrer c'était la dernière partie
[Musique]
je pense que du coup je dois pas jouer
je dois pas jouer échec enfin surtout
quand il a le ranger deux et que j'ai la
tour en a encore je dois je dois le
laisser dans ce sport là parce qu'en
fait son tour cavalier pion sur cette
table là ça va nulle part on peut pas je
sais pas je vois pas la position mais je
sais qu'il peut pas je sais qu'il peut
pas bouger ah oui c'est vrai que tu vois
pas là
là je crois que l'ordi mamie foi qui est
fort avec un peu la même idée mais en
beaucoup mieux parce que en fait je
menace 3 2 et je veux prendre avec le
fou pour garder l'oeil sur le pion et en
fait c'est juste complètement
facile c'est final avec le pion le pion
sur la Colona wash quand j'ai la tour
derrière c'est jamais facile de pousser
le pion et avec le fou moi je me sentais
assez bien pour faire annuler assez
facile mais en fait il a répété deux
fois et je me suis complètement
déconcentré je me suis dit nul je
pensais à ce que j'allais jouer pas la
dernière sur sa française et
je prends F2
qu'il faut attendre mais tu joues quoi
genre F6 ou plutôt raquette
déjà ça a l'air un peu compliqué genre
il fait des trucs genre 6 ou 3 une bouge
un peu dans tous les sens et en fait tu
peux pas trop avancer
de rabattement donc
maintenant tu as moyen de manger dans
tous les cas ça sent que c'est c'est nul
après
H4 c'est un peu
j'étais super content je m'attendais
oui c'est ça oui un truc
d'abord je pense que H5 est peut-être un
peu plus précis je voulais pas laisser
des chèques mais bon ça changera et
quand tu m'as fait G3 je me suis dit bah
ça joue la oui je meurs de peine
je le vois pas
j'ai trois
donné par l'ordi
il mange G4 semble plus
c'est pour ça que je regretter G7 je
pense que à ce moment je dois d'abord
jouer à 5 pour le bloquer
il a bien joué écoute la première
effectivement ce que tu disais on va
peut-être revenir sur la première qui
est aussi critique qui fait que la
première je m'en suis voulu aussi
je pense bien voulu surtout ça c'est
jouer ou il a il a fait un truc hop un
peu innocent mais
pas si pas si en fait ce truc je le
connais je sais que
parce que je sais que l'ordi mais que
c'est absolument rien pour les blancs et
en fait quand il me l'a joué je me suis
dit en fait c'est pas si facile
ça s'est vu parce que lui il a raté un
avantage j'ai pris du temps parce qu'en
fait ça peut aller je connaissais cette
idée en fait il m'a fait de la F4 pour
la marche 4 avec un peu créer des trucs
et j'ai oublié en fait c'est pas qu'il y
avait les dessins c'est fou aussi ce qui
est très fort d'accord
en fait c'est vraiment là par contre je
crois qu'après vous aussi c'est vraiment
pas dangereux
parce que
de 5 avec le vis-à-vis sur programme
quoi ouais en fait vous aussi
ça va ça peut aller mais il y a des
trucs où je peux faire [__] en ces
trois et puis je voulais pas je voulais
pas jouer ça contre lui parce que c'est
super dangereux
c'est qu'en plus je voulais jouer
tranquille parce qu'il est tellement
forte et
et j'avais l'occasion dans ce cavalier
F5 après la F4
non non après 2e
fois 5 parce que cavalier alors comment
tu fais pour égaliser je prends d'âme
prend ça me prend puis on prend C3
en fait j'avais peur de tourner 3
quelque chose comme ça tourner 3 tours
F3 mais en fait j'imagine qu'il y a même
des idées où je peux laisser le pion F5
et juste attaquer avec B5 à 5b4 contre
jeu là bas en fait le pion F5 c'est vrai
que j'ai eu peur de le perdre mais il
perd tellement de temps à le prendre sa
tour vous devez un peu mal placé et en
fait mon FC c'est super fort et ça j'ai
pas compris du coup j'ai joué 5 en
pensant que il va jouer dame CE1
et pas du tout on a joué dame 4 et là je
me suis senti vraiment stupide parce que
du coup c'est vraiment c'est clairement
moins bien après je sais pas à quel
point c'est moins bien mais c'est mais
c'est moins bien et puis c'est pas
agréable
c'est pas grave parce que mes pièces
sont bizarres mes pièces sont bizarres
donc il revient pas en plus j'ai joué
bessier donc j'ai les cases blanches
ça peut jouer
et il y a une dernière occasion c'est
quand je fais d'habitude
je pense
j'ai hésité je sais pas pourquoi
parce que c'était mon plan de d'essayer
d'échanger
l'année dernière dans le même format et
je l'avais battu dans une finale
d'accord qui ressemble à rien et puis il
avait vraiment mal joué je me suis dit
que en regardant surtout c'est parti et
c'est des faits j'ai vu que c'était
souvent des trucs où il est
le truc où il est moins à l'aise c'est
plutôt les finales donc pour les finales
où il a 16 sort vraiment sympathique au
final un peu plates
déjà les dominer Maxime Vacher La Grave
d'une façon incroyable
c'était incroyable que en fait il est
malin dans les ouvertures aussi parce
que moi je peux dire que je me suis pas
préparé parce qu'il joue vraiment
beaucoup de trucs et il m'a trouvé
encore un petit une petite ligne qui
connaît alors dans la deuxième dans le
de la deuxième où il est noir je crois
que je l'ai un peu eu
parce que je pense qu'il avait pas grand
chose je sais pas à quel point la finale
dans la deuxième je sais pas d'ailleurs
si il a raté un truc un peu ce truc là
apparemment
en fait
j'avais préparé un truc à me sens que je
connaissais plus
j'avais eu plein ou ça cherche à faire
du lait avec les Blancs et en plus
c'était pas un mauvais choix pour lui de
jouer sans risque voilà
il faut que tu gagnes la dernière il
faut gagner
dans derrière enfin c'est quand même pas
mal quand tu mets un demi zéro et demi
de faire une lune dans la troisième ça
c'est quand même assez raisonnable
mais après en fait bizarrement je
pensais qu'après ça allait être
tranquille et puis en fait je sais pas
j'ai pas trouvé de trucs simples pour
pour faire mieux je sais pas à quel
point c'est facile
parce que ce que j'ai fait c'est
évidemment pas le meilleur de donner le
plan
on va peut-être mettre la
c'est ça c'est vrai que oui c'est jamais
complètement je sais pas on a on
arrêtait en fait on croyait en toi là on
s'est dit ça va faire nul ouais on a
arrêté de regarder on allait voir Ali
resa où c'était bouillante ici et bah
c'était tellement bouillante ici qu'il a
perdu
contre Colars et qu'il est en danger là
il s'est qualifié en ce tournoi écoute
c'est quoi le moment où
donc ça j'ai vu je me suis dit vraiment
ça c'est complètement égal et en fait
j'ai pas trouvé le truc le plus simple
je m'embrouiller quelque part parce que
ça doit vraiment être
comme ça
d'abord
[Musique]
C4
c'est dur d'imaginer que tu vas la
perdre celle-là quand même
ouais mais en fait c'est là où je m'en
veux parce que je me suis vraiment
déconcentré déjà à ce moment là quand je
pensais que c'était trop facile et puis
après quand je pensais qu'il y avait
très très impressionnant à ce niveau là
aussi c'est qu'il est
habité je le vois à la cave moi aussi je
l'ai à la cam alors là je l'ai pas mis
parce qu'il me rend nerveux à bouger
dans tous les sens mais je le vois il
lâche rien
demain donc tu rejoues tu rejoues
shimanov donc bon ça va ouais ça mais
j'aimerais bien comme ça rejoins un mec
parce que du coup j'imagine que si je
viens rejoindre un top j'espère me
réveiller un peu et être un peu plus
sérieux
ouais mais là c'est vraiment
grosse
essayer de faire un truc dans la
dernière ou même si je fais nul ça peut
être assez sérieux tu vois mais
après sur sa France
il avait aussi contre maxime a été très
malin dans les débuts
il travaille bien il est jeune il est
ambitieux
est-ce que tu penses que
3 qu'il aura un shot au titre mondial un
jour oh bah je pense parce que j'ai vu
en fait il a 18 ou 19 18
19 enfin il vient d'avoir
je pense surtout que j'ai vu c'est parti
je peux dire que
c'est pas facile de trouver c'est pas
faible il est né en 2004 ouais donc
c'est ça l'année prochaine il avait 20
ans ok
je pense en tout cas c'est clair facile
18 septembre 2004 ouais donc attends il
a
18 ans il va avoir 19 en septembre donc
archi impressionnant et probablement un
futur challenger et peut-être d'ailleurs
très rapidement
c'était pas possible c'est pas il est
pas si loin est-ce que tu le trouves
loin de derrière ça quand même ou
honnêtement pas du tout ok en tout cas
dans ces cadence alors peut-être qu'il
le prend plus au sérieux j'ai
l'impression qu'il prend vraiment au
sérieux ces trucs internet quand je vois
c'est parti il a toujours des petites
idées avec les Blancs surtout il est
toujours
il y a toujours un petit truc un petit
système
et
avec les Noirs ils jouent tout il a
l'impression qu'il connaît tout il se
rappelle de tout je pense qu'il a une
super mémoire en voyant c'est parti il a
que 19 ans et vraiment je sais pas je
connais bien
beaucoup de temps
je pense qu'il a tout pour
aller ça c'est clair
bravo à lui en tout cas bah écoute on se
retrouve demain contre shimanov ouais
bah ça va
pardon on se voit entre midi
ouais mais bon justement c'est ça le
principe du truc c'est pas mal encore tu
peux encore tout raser
surtout j'aimerais bien refaire un match
avec
j'aimerais bien ne pas reprendre
des quarts de finale
je sais pas quoi m'attendre
là aujourd'hui
mais bon donc on verra demain mais en
tout cas il va falloir que je me
réveille un peu
les autres c'était pas le meilleur
c'était pas le meilleur appareil pour
commencer ça c'est clair bon et merci
beaucoup
je m'attendais pas il y a pas de
problème
honnêtement je viens de voir ce que va
donner contre Carola par exemple
je crois qu'il est dans le dans le
deuxième tu vois il y en aka qui est
quand même qui est là au-dessus dans ces
trucs internet
mais je crois qu'il est en deuxième
paquet défavoris avec Ali resa et
carbone ouais mais même honnêtement on
verra parce que ça peut être très très
chaud demain contre
tout ce qu'il a mis à Maxime
sont un truc
c'est plus vraiment une surprise
maintenant j'ai envie de dire
c'était vraiment il manquait pas un
joueur
donc ouais donc pas à rougir de cette de
ce match ça c'est clair
mais bon bref
c'est pas grave
ok bah écoute
merci beaucoup
j'avais parlé on refait notre notre duo
à 7 dimanche
et on se bat à la fin
qui est passé nous voir alors je vais
vous remettre la vue normale parce que
là j'avais tout changé
pour que
[Musique]
tout changer pour que Laurent puisse
venir enfin pour que Jules puisse nous
voir
effectivement pas
le meilleur apparument pour commencer
franchement c'est dur ouais c'est pas le
pire c'est peut-être nickel deuxième
pire c'est
pas facile non plus et allez ça non plus
non mais c'est vrai c'est ce qu'il a dit
un division 1 bon
ils ont un ça joue très fort il y a rien
à dire
Shakira est payé très très cher
de venir nous voir demain on espère
qu'il va qui va briller il va revenir
nous voir et on va parler de comment il
a massacré Shimano et puis vous savez
comme une le dit il gagne de
l'expérience aussi parce que Jules faut
savoir qu'il a quand même progressé il a
fait des gros progrès sur le Tarn il a
été
je crois grand maître à 22 ans
donc tu vois ce qui est assez tard pour
un joueur de ce niveau et donc c'est
vrai que on sent déjà
il commence à avoir beaucoup plus
d'expérience
mais ça lui manque encore un petit peu
les matchs contre les les top top
loueurs déjà aux Olympiades aux
Olympiades de première échec il a gagné
beaucoup beaucoup d'expérience
mais voilà c'est important pour lui de
jouer de jouer ses joueurs et
d'apprendre et pourquoi pas
plus tard de les battre tout simplement
surtout dans c'est rapide il est quand
même
il est quand même très très fort Julien
rapide c'est peut-être ça je sais pas ça
meilleur cadence avec le Blitz mais en
tout cas ouais il est il est très
dangereux
et on a Ali resa firuga qui lui aussi en
parlant de très dangereux
et là et il est dos au mur allez doit
absolument l'emporter dans cette
quatrième partie pour revenir à deux
partout et ensuite ils devra remporter
l'Armageddon donc pas une mince affaire
contre ce Collard ce qui nous fait une
grosse impression qui a perdu la
première
mais qui depuis c'est quand même très
très bien battu
il est même il est en tête tout
simplement
contre
une position avec paire de fou
contre paire de cavaliers mais un roi un
petit peu dans les courants d'air 21e
coup et pas encore ok ça fait peur ça
fait peur mais
il faut ce qu'il faut pour gagner avec
les Noirs
quand même pour les Noirs au vu du pion
isolé en E5 au vu de la paire de fou
le long terme on est très très bien avec
la non ça fait petit rock pour des 8 bon
mais on gagne mais le problème c'est
qu'il faut réussir
à l'organiser et donc Ali Reza qui doit
absolument gagner en cette partie
envoyer le score avec des mené il est
mené de 1 et c'est la dernière partie
donc en cas d'égalité ou fin de
match nul ou de victoire de l'allemand
Dimitri Collard et ben Dimitri sera
qualifié pour du coup le demi-finale
comme je et voilà c'est ça donc en cas
de
non victoire de Ali resa ici et ben il
sera pas éliminé encore il sera juste
dans la poule de pervers mais il sera
encore en vie
et donc avoir quelques cinq en penses
c'est pas un bon coup
alors est-ce que je peux pas est-ce que
vous prendrez 5 il faut calculer fous
en fait
pour ça que c'est pas bon ouais ça ça a
l'air trop dangereux tour des tour D1
bon assez vite d'un point aussi si on
prend sur échec OK
donc petit rock et cavaliers
[Musique]
OK
il veut le matin là c'est au moins c'est
clair net et précis il veut faire KVF 6
échec qu'est-ce qui se passe sur dame
prend B2
menace
tout simplement et d'ailleurs surtout
AB1 je voulais faire quand j'ai 5 pour
montrer à quel point
il y a encore maths
[Musique]
tu vas voir H6
évidemment mais H6 c'est joli juste pour
montrer que cette dame peut vraiment pas
bouger
mais peut-être profiter de la dame
contre ici pour faire tomber maintenant
ouais mais je prends un pion
déjà pour commencer ça c'est fait
c'est vrai ok c'est le pion il y a plus
il y a plus à le faire
en cas d'égalité le départage c'est du
ensuite c'est une seule partie armaguée
donc ça veut dire un magoton c'est que
les Noirs en cas de nul et bien il
remporte le match donc il y a forcément
un vainqueur et là il y a une mise une
enchère qui commence pour avoir les
noirs et donc ce droit de faire nul et
donc il faut lâcher un peu de temps et
donc voilà par exemple si il y a les
raisins fait une enchère à 11 minutes
compte 4 toute façon les blancs en 15
minutes les Noirs il dit 11 minutes
collars dit 11 minutes 02 et bien allez
Reza allez noir parce qu'il a fait une
meilleure enchère et donc il a 11
minutes
contre 15 avec les Noirs ce qui est très
désavantageux mais il a le gros avantage
de pouvoir faire nul et donc on a des
choses assez amusantes bon le truc à peu
près établi c'est que le truc à peu près
ferme c'est-à-dire équitable c'est 9
minutes c'est entre 9 et 10 minutes un
peu plus ces trois avantageux pour les
Noirs un peu moins c'est trop avantageux
pour les blancs c'est à peu près je
crois vu les enchères qu'on a vu n'avait
précédent tournois c'est ce qui a été
communément
je dirais sans sans le dire évidemment
mais en tout cas ils sont à peu près
tous d'accord sur ça les tops joueurs
voilà donc ça tourne autour de 9 minutes
c'est du chaos jusqu'au bout donc ça
flag et tout ça sachant que online si on
n'est pas trop handicapé de la souris
comme un de vos serviteurs on joue quand
même plus de coup que
en vrai beaucoup plus de coup parce
qu'on peut PRIMOVE on peut jouer en une
seconde on peut jouer même il y a des
gens qui arrivent à jouer en 15 secondes
certains ils jouent des parties en
entier donc on peut jouer énormément de
coups en une seconde tu me disais ouais
le primov il prend 01 donc ça veut dire
qu'on peut jouer 10 coups
qui évidemment complètement impossible
en dans une partie réelle avec pendule
donc voilà on va voir et on va
probablement avoir un petit break ça va
être sympa ça ça serait bien qu'il gagne
quand même il faut qu'il a gagné
pour toi
alors on a la caméra qui est bien revenu
dans ce match il y a un et demi par tout
et dans la dernière
et bien c'est chaud mais Yordan pas mal
de pions pour la qualité bon à peu près
équilibré peut-être notre Armageddon à
venir et Fabiano cajouana a tout
simplement gagner son match tout comme
nord du bec Abdou Sator face à Jules il
se retrouveront dès demain tandis que
shimanov et Jules se retrouveront dans
le loser bracket mais rappelons que rien
n'est terminé en fait on peut gagner le
tournoi
même en ayant perdu un match
c'est la beauté du format
alors comment on fait la Tourer
vraiment
j'aime bien même des deux c'est ça c'est
pas mal
ça peut être ça peut faire peur
non mais le problème c'est que ta dame
est vraiment surchargée ça cauchemar
sur
un entourage 4 non surtout
ça attaque des deux et ça menace tour
des trois et ça empêche aussi
et ça garde un œil sur le Cavaillon G5
c'est ton jamais
mais
c'est pas facile de gagner face à un
joueur aussi solide que Collard
sur demande
oh là là il t'a vu ce qu'il a fait dans
le début ou pas va voir va voir montre
toute la partie s'il te plaît
montre toute la partie
merci et regardez ouvre bien les yeux
cavalier
en tilt le tilt derrière
c'est pas beau
que
plutôt possible
aussi clairement et là il est pas mal
d'un coup
ouais on a eu cette position avec les
deux fous là
[Musique]
tout simplement
et voilà comment on est arrivé là
un peu une sorte de service à la
cuillère
bon moi je l'ai eu hein
en partie officielle au champion du
monde de [__] le
4 cavalier
du monde de Blitz où c'était quand même
important et d'ailleurs ça a très bien
marché j'ai refusé la répétition dans
cette partie parce que les gens se
moquent que j'ai perdu c'est un j'ai
perdu on est d'accord mais un moment il
répétait et je pouvais répéter et je me
suis dit non mais bon je joue que j'ai 8
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces histoires
faut quand même se faire respecter
évidemment trois coups plus tard je vais
pour faire nul et j'ai perdu 10 coups
plus tard
et j'ai la fierté parfois faut savoir
s'asseoir dessus
j'ai pas su
c'est comme ça
alors H4
qui va forcer les choses en plus je vais
gagner au 5 sur la chaîne ouais c'est ça
il est il a joué à 5 non je commence un
petit peu à déteindre sur toi enfin tu
commences un peu sur moi mais après tu
finis en division comme Jules tu vois
tes résultats augmente
il était temps quand même
vous savez voilà c'est ça
comment il a fait roi H2 bon c'est
compris
une minute 50
on peut aller voir Naka parce que là
franchement je vois pas ce qui va se
passer ouais on reviendra évidemment
chez aliarmageddon l'armée
ta caméra elle est encore je pensais
cette qualité pour deux pions et
effectivement
alors les blancs poussent gentiment mais
il va pas rester assez de pion pour la
gagner celle-là donc ça va faire nul
ouais on va avoir on va avoir des beaux
des partages
et salut
Royal salut à toi timon vive la France
salut à toi
et
skyful et il a perdu notre ami Jules il
est quand même venu il est quand même
venu
et on rappelle le mot bot bonjour mon
pote
le site d'échec sécurisé est fiable pour
que vos enfants apprennent et jouer aux
échecs oui ça c'est très important dans
le Cheskin truc qu'on m'a appris c'est
qu'il y a tu vois c'est à l'américaine
c'est un adulte qui vient parler à des
enfants il fait il fait 10 ans de prison
voilà donc il y a tu un adulte qui est
pas tu vois qui serait un anonyme par
exemple comme ça arrive souvent sur
Internet ou voilà si vous êtes parents
je suppose que voilà vous avez déjà eu
peur de ce genre de choses ou c'est vrai
qu'avec Internet on peut parler à
différents différentes personnes
les enfants un peu naïfs peuvent
commencer à parler voilà bon
c'est donc là c'est très très
surveillant toutes les conversations
sont surveillées donc vous avez pas
besoin d'être
disons 100% du temps derrière votre
enfant c'est très bien réglementé
réglementé pardon c'est vraiment c'est
une c'est un truc cadré à l'américaine
donc ça c'est vraiment très très
important
de savoir que vos enfants seront dans un
environnement
tout à fait sain et
des surveiller
qui n'est pas le cas je vais mettre un
petit tac là tiens ce qui n'est pas le
cas sur d'autres sites gratuits par
exemple
c'est quand même c'est en fait tu payes
un abonnement mais tu as quand même un
service derrière et notamment ça donc
voilà qui permet de voilà de dormir
mieux
donc
on a cette finale
attention
que si un résultat c'est terminé ouais
c'est terminé n'a qu'à en grosse
souffrance clairement
si un résultat
que si
la jauge jeudi qu'est-ce que je vous dis
j'ai pas vous dire le contraire
on a cassé le roi de la défense
attention
mais quand même là apparemment
objectivement il est perdant il va
trouver les meilleurs ressources comme
d'habitude
hyper raciste j'ai l'impression que il
pense que
c'est une catastrophe pour Naka il est
pas content du tout il y avait tout
gagné
mais il se bat il comme d'hab hein
c'est gagné et pour yandere quelle
surprise
quelle surprise incroyable ce match où
il pèse
c'est vrai qu'on a plus passé de temps
sur les Français on a vu très vite que
votre forêt la première partie
incroyable et en plus on a parlé on
avait dit que avant de Forest c'est un
joueur qui est qui est clairement
capable de de sortir Nakamura
parce que c'est un joueur qui est qui
est extrêmement extrêmement dangereux et
de faire des exploits
il est vraiment pas content
alors tous les gens qui viennent sont
pas des
peuvent faire des des choses incroyables
gagner vaikanzé c'est incroyable parce
que c'est du 13 ronde c'est plus grand
tournoi au monde
donc c'est pas c'est pas une mince
affaire et on aura Naka dans le look
dans le loser market il se lève donc il
a dû abandonner
il était pas content du tout et bien oui
ça arrive de se faire surprendre il
menace assis il a pas abandonné il
laisse tourner sa pendule BAM bamaka
[Applaudissements]
c'est
parti il est parti
il devrait prendre un non mais là
franchement c'est pas normal
et il part et victoire d'ailleurs donne
bravo et ordonne franchement belle
partie baumatch et il y a rien qui se
qualifie pour pour les demi-finales
alors je peux vous dire qu'on qui va
jouer hein
qui va affronter le gagnant de de fille
rousse jacolar qu'on sait pas encore qui
c'est l'armée
avec Nakamura je vois contre le perdant
de ces deux joueurs
et donc en tout cas plein de petites
parties à suivre ça va ça va être hyper
intéressant de voir déjà on a shimanov
contre contre Jules demain on aura Naka
contre le père avant de Furu jacolars on
aura karwana Center off et on aura van
forest entre le gagnant de FEAR rouge
jacolars donc dans les deux cas c'est
des grosses parties à suivre
et ça doit être c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour les raisins qui gagne cet
Armageddon
on n'a pas été de dire mais
j'en éternue je te remercie c'est pas
bah c'est pas d'accord pas d'accord
c'est quand même c'est quand même
beaucoup plus abordable que Naka ouais
donc très très bonne nouvelle pour notre
petit resa manque te faire plaisir et
oui
alors être énervé aussi mais on peut
abandonner aussi et au lieu de laisser
filer son temps c'est pas faire plus
c'est puni sur chaise comme
je sais que moi ça m'est arrivé que il y
a des joueurs voilà quand on se laisse
tomber comme ça ils sont ils prennent
[Musique]
ils prennent quand même quelque chose de
carton jaune ouais pour commencer
le plaisir de le battre en live il m'a
battu plus souvent mais j'ai quand même
le plaisir de le battre il se lève il se
rappelle la main voilà c'est pas
quelqu'un de très de très sportif à la
fin des fêtes et encore pire évidemment
quand il s'y attend pas ou quand il
considère que c'est un résultat qui est
pas normal où il a raison d'ailleurs il
est favori quand tu leur donnes c'est un
meilleur joueur de rapide coyrun c'est
sûr mais bon il redonne a fait son match
et il a le droit de
il a le droit de faire un bon match
c'est comme ça donc voilà
ouais bien sûr il dit qu'il s'en fout du
non mais il raconte n'importe quoi de
toute façon
évidemment il serait pas là numéro 5
mondial on le rappelle à éteindre gentil
on nous fait pas le coup
on se fait un petit on a les enchères ou
pas est-ce que tu as des pubs alors moi
j'ai rien mais après si tu veux si j'en
ai une chaîne ou pas attends je vais
voir
donc non je sais pas j'ai pas d'enchères
mais je sais pas on va l'avoir bientôt
je pense
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les deux joueurs
ils font les enchères avec l'arbitre qui
est dans la salle du coup moi ils m'ont
j'ai pas eu d'armaguette mais j'ai vu
comment ça marchait en gros ce qu'ils
disent au début du match si un partout
vous envoyer un message privé évidemment
à l'arbitre qui se trouve dans le zoom
call avec votre temps avec votre enchère
et donc voilà pour avoir les noirs
donc c'est je sais pas comment faire
avec Ali resa ça c'est tellement bien
passé avec les je sais pas est-ce que ça
s'est bien passé ou pas je pense que les
a quand même il va
je vois les raisins fait un 8,50
les colas ouais 8,50 pour aller résa et
Collard il va dire plus voilà c'est mon
pronom moi je le dis un petit
un petit 8
non
pour aller à
non et je te dirai un
il va dire 10 minutes voilà quoi ouais
un 957 ouais c'est ça un truc comme ça
combien 9 23 on a 8 23 23 et 9 57 moi
j'ai dit 8 8 8 50 c'est ça
et l'autre 10
quand on est d'accord mais bon on va
voir peut-être que on va être surpris et
ils sont ils sont partis
à LG qui dit on le salue notre ami
champion de France junior attention
de Limoges c'est bien la première fois
champion de France junior je pense que
c'est une première bravo à toi
et surtout d'où tu viens tu vois
i'm not naturali talented ouais non
évidemment qu'il est qu'il est hyper
talentueux comment ça pas de voiture
Sims à montrer tu rigoles non j'en ai
pas un et deux merci on les remercie de
nous suivre dans cette belle aventure et
de nous offrir un air pur grâce à en
tout cas de nous permettre de voir si
notre ère est pure et s'il y a pas de
radon
le radon est très dangereux pour la
santé partez de chez vous il y a du
radon
je suis nouveau dans les échecs nous dit
cuit qui Ruan Shadow et je me prends de
passion mais avec 310 hello c'est
compliqué ne t'inquiète pas tout le
monde a été débutant
ça c'est quand même c'est le point
commun qu'on a tous on a tous été
débutants alors certains
certains ont été pris de passion comme
toi bah je crois que si on est là
globalement on a tous été à
peu près été pris de passion
tu vas faire des progrès ne t'inquiète
pas
après le truc c'est de
se faire plaisir comme pour tout sans
avoir des objectifs des mesures
et deuxième fois du coup à gérer l'eau
qui nous rappelle quand même qu'il a été
sur votre face cadet j'ai dit junior tu
as pas été champion l'année dernière
[Musique]
j'en tire une certaine gloire je vais
voir si j'ai un message non c'est pas
lui j'ai un message quelqu'un d'autre
voir si j'ai quelque chose sur le
broadcast alors moi je l'ai Ali resa fir
rouge à 8,20 bravo bravo stuff
239 tu vois on l'avait vu un peu trop de
9 57
donc allez résa à les Noirs non je me
suis dit d'être mal au temps et que il
allait mettre l'accent il voulait
vraiment les Noirs je pense et je pense
c'est quand même
bah c'est sûr on peut faire nul mais en
fait donc
[Musique]
les Noirs dans cette partie avec 8
minutes 20 contre 15 minutes c'est du
chaos c'est du chaos donc
on peut flag
tout à fait
et il y a même
il y a même en fait c'est juste ça fait
partie du jeu il y a pas être offusqué
que d'autres mais oui il y a aussi ça
tout à fait mais bon peu importe moi tu
sais je suis je suis très
je suis très humble par rapport à ça
parce que je peux te dire qu'au tennis
j'ai commencé le tennis avant les échecs
et je suis resté toujours très très
modeste tu vois c'est genre
j'ai jamais je pense que mon niveau là
c'est 1600 hello tu vois 71700 allez les
bonjour les grands jours c'est 1800 tu
vois non mais j'ai joué et j'ai commencé
à avoir les échecs donc je peux te dire
ça ça fait un petit moment donc voilà et
je m'amuse j'adore regarder le tennis
j'adore y jouer voilà je m'amuse
mais je crois que c'est le plus
important au final
après est-ce que tu as est-ce que tu as
mis autant d'efforts dans le tennis que
dans les échecs au début j'ai vite
compris que je
n'avais plus souvent aux échecs
[Rires]
il y avait tu sais quand tu fais un
dimanche sur deux à faire une
compétition tennis ou tu repars tu vois
les trois balles du perdant et que le
dimanche d'après tu vas trouver des
chèques tu as la Coupe du Monde
au moins de ta catégorie d'âge ou en
fait tu as toujours une coupe qui gagne
toujours un truc
quand même quand tu es un minimum
compétiteur
pas du coup tu continues plus
sérieusement les échelles je crois que
c'est normal
non il y a pas du tout d'un crémant
au repêche 10
ouais alors est-ce qu'il y a des stats
ouais ça serait une ça serait
intéressant ça
je sais pas
je pense que niveau de cheesecom oui
parce que mais bon ça c'est privé enfin
on avait
fait sur les airbags
en fait une fois on avait vu plus ou
moins il y avait pas les stats mais
c'était une sorte de de
d'un ordinateur qui devine à la place
des joueurs
[Musique]
qui demande joueur préféré au tennis
Laval
évidemment le besoin
trop fan de Roland-Garros pour pas être
fan de Nadal
game du style quoi il se bat j'adore
j'ai jamais vaincu
alors notre petit Aires en tout cas peu
importe des stats il a il a quand même 8
20 donc il va falloir faire vite
dans cette partie il va pas pouvoir se
permettre de faire un kg enfin il peut
se permettre mais bon ça serait risqué
on attend
mais on est d'accord de 69100 qui dit en
débutant ne veut pas dire qu'on prend
pas de plaisir oui tout à fait
une compétiteur quand déjà ton niveau
mais bien sûr évidemment mais bon après
voilà j'étais gamin ouais je préfère
gagner quoi voilà c'est tout
on a changé
de braquer là niveau Ali resa plus de
blagues petite berlinoise tout Rouen un
peu étonnant mais peut-être qu'il a une
petite idée Colars il est préparé avant
le match
pourquoi pas en trois semaines tant
qu'on y est
déjà 3 ans ça sera déjà pas mal voilà
c'est très dur c'est très dur
salut amical à matou 33 m'a tout 33 qui
est le qui après quand tout va avoir son
titre de mi il sera le plus fort il
deviendra le plus fort mettre idée de
France
pendant très longtemps
mais bon j'ai pas encore j'ai pas encore
gagné cette course
j'ai pas encore bâtiment 500
parce que franchement
le pauvre
alors foot3 ouais ok bon ça c'est très
très léger il a il a fait un dessin qui
assez rapide pour prendre de l'espace au
centre et donc être un tantinet mieux
avec les Blancs
bon c'est clairement une prépa de la
part de Colars allez raisins qui
réfléchit pas mal attention plus que 7
minutes tu vois
tu dis il a du temps il a du temps dès
qu'il y a un petit problème à régler tu
vois si tu fais KFC dame D4 il va faire
à 4 à 5 moi je connais un petit peu ces
positions c'est pas évident pour les
Noirs je sais d'ailleurs je pense qu'il
a il a pas joué hyper précis
ça a l'air très facile à jouer pour
c'est vrai que ce problème de fou par
exemple non mais je crois qu'il a pas
été très précis dans le dans le début
honnêtement
à lire les il a joué une ligne un peu
inférieure c'est un peu étonnant
d'ailleurs mais bon attention on aime
les quatre esquives pas faire que j'ai
quatre dames 6
tu connais mes réflexes
et mettre le tour en 8
attention le problème c'est ton aile
dame il y a toujours le pion à 7 qui va
traîner et si tu jouais à 6 je vais
jouer dame BK
et les cases blanches même des fois on
peut même venir avec une tour en C3 ou
une dame en C4 taper sur C7
il y a plein de routes partout
il y a eu assez
c'est je trouve ça très dur à jouer ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a joué
le même temps ils ont dépensé deux
minutes chacun mais
au départ quoi 6 minutes 40 donc
tout à fait normal
peut-être il peut manger quand même il
faudrait
je dis pas que une position
à 5 qui fixe un peu la dame alors on
peut faire des plans marrants tu
reprends le 3 tours B8 damasset pour
essayer de sortir Adam comme ça et en
fait après je vais faire je veux faire
tout revit aussi et Madame elle contrôle
bien la dame elle contrôle bien les
cases noires il faut voir si ça marche
ça me planthématique là il peut retirer
trois tu vois par exemple
je sais pas c'est question auxquelles on
n'aime pas trop répondre
8 et espérer que rien ne passe allait le
roi pour les blancs mais j'avais de
garantie sur ce genre de
de position
s faiblesse
on va voir et en tout cas cette minute
d'avance pour le joueur allemand
pour l'instant je trouve
une idée ouais pour le C4
[Musique]
et on a bien la case des 4 pour le
cavalier ça peut être intéressant c'est
plein d'options
encore y aller c'est pas
c'est pas même dessin que vous
libérateur ben écoute je pense que je
vais quand même te prendre un jour un
truc
processus il faut prendre un 6 ça peut
être très vite très mauvais ça va pas du
tout
ça devrait muzanne on te conseille pas
de lâcher tes études pour passer de 400
à 2000 effectivement
un plan de carrière
pas aux échecs en tout cas
après on peut donner des cours dans les
écoles et choses formidables à faire oui
oui à moi même à 1500 faire apprendre à
jouer aux échecs mais ouais bon
en tout cas je sais pas quel âge tu as
mais en tout cas ouais parles-en à tes
parents
[Rires]
alors cavalier F4 bien joué parce que ça
c'est une idée
ça me fait pas rêver mais non je
comprends
au moins le rendre plus difficile
j'ai pensé à un truc qui marche pas
dommage c'est assez joli
pensez à cavalage 5 et sur cavalier 6 ça
va être un projet 7 et qui valait là
qu'elle va aller prendre la harpe comme
ça tout à l'heure sauf que
malheureusement le fou des fois en
cavaliers mais c'était assez joli
je prends du cavalier a priori et je
fais dame 3 un truc comme ça j'essaie de
forcer à jouer une française
j'ai un fou qui est très
mauvaise affaibli donc ça ça a l'air
quand même sympa
ouais certainement les blancs sont mieux
je crois que c'est assez indiscutable
après à quel point c'est toujours pareil
c'est 4 ok intéressant
ouais on sait l'échiquier life ce serait
bien je suis d'accord après c'est les
trucs
devant ma bouche
donc si
et puis en plus là je suis au maximum
mais j'ai comme plan de me racheter un
micro de façon bientôt
plan de carrière son cavalier
menace
pas très discrète
il est foutu les raisins
qui est pas content
et en plus le pire la mauvaise nouvelle
pour lui c'est que si il perd et ben il
va jouer contre Nakamura quoi
dès demain et ouais on parlait des deux
favoris tournoi qui vont se jouer pour
la sortir c'est un peu comme si tu avais
tu avais Djokovic le joueur Roland
Garros dans la poule des parents quoi
il est complètement foutu là on est
d'accord hein
ça a l'air ça a l'air complètement
complètement en plus tu vois ce pion il
est là et puis affreux
et même pas fait quoi c'est même pas
3 minutes 40 une poubelle
et trouver une solution il y a une prise
bouger la dame mais bon après à 6
franchement pas très agréable
on a passé le stade de pas très agréable
c'est juste perdant en fait bon après
perdant
tu peux mettre cavalier en J3 aussi tu
avais plein de choses
mais là c'est clair que les noirs
peuvent gagner pour pour
obtenir
non bien sûr il y a toujours une chance
mais le problème c'est qu'il a 5 minutes
de moins et une position probablement
objectivement perdante avec ce pion a
peut filer Adams favoriser un impact des
blancs ici
je crois que cavale F4 moi j'aime bien
qu'il y avait F4 mais bon le problème
c'est que je gagne jamais c'est parti
après
mais oui qui avait les F4 a l'air sympa
parce que les finales ont l'air quand
même très très avantageuses pour les
blancs
est-ce que c'est joué je pense mais dans
l'imbécile tu vas essayer de jouer à
cette
ça ouvre des échecs
pardon du contrôle
même si c'est une erreur d'après
l'ordinateur
donc là il y a plus de il veut
clairement F5 et ça ça a l'air quand
même très très bien
qu'on risque
pas un bon coup non plus mais bon ok
finale
[Musique]
B8
très très loin comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait trouver du jeu parce que c'est
quand même un gros problème
[Musique]
simplement pour aller résa contre 7,30
pour Colars le joueur allemand en
contrôle
qui nous fait une sacrée surprise
qui veut essayer d'avoir du contrôle
avec ça mais ok j'ai beaucoup de mal à y
croire mais écoute
allez plus que la pendule de 30 pour
pour les raisins
et
5 attention
qui pourrait faire douter un peu
l'adversaire
franchement je trouve que c'est pas si
facile si
moi celle-là je stresse hein
ça reste pas mal mais genre si tu dois
faire ça par exemple bah écoute
justifie justifie qu'elle va aller
prendre un six par exemple
si tu prends 6 tu prends des trois je
sais pas tu prends
c'est un matos
pour résumer la situation
est-ce que ça marchait je vais regarder
ça mais j'ai pas vu comment ça marche et
il prend des trois qui allait prendre un
pense que l'idée
c'est bien
complètement fraise ensuite il reste
deux minutes à la pendule après elle le
voit faire
sur sur Internet c'est très chèque est
décatois
tellement naturel il fait du ultra
Bullet du 15 secondes ou 30 ils ont en
30 secondes
énormément mais après il faut pas trop
il faut pas non plus trop
fier à ça parce que
[Musique]
quand est-ce que mon Bullet tu as
toujours du lag et tu peux pas trop trop
là il arrive à une minute 25
ça commence à être très chaud et sur
chaque il a peur de quoi
waouh
ok ça c'est pas la moitié d'un coup bon
là il gaffe à tous les coups la position
est trop dur à jouer en fait maintenant
correct
j'aime bien ça aussi je menaces des
échecs aussi qui sont pas mal j'ai trois
ouais dame j'ai trois hyper fort je suis
d'accord
mais après faut voir d'un point racisme
mais bon
comme ça
et suivant
mais j'ai peut-être eu encore
[Musique]
et chaque roi là
et je pensais un F6 non
même en couleur mais tu as pas la main
il a plus de temps en plus
et en dessous largement en dessous et
voilà Collard
par rapport à les raisins mais bon il a
pris sa chance écoute il a bien eu
raison allez aza était pas dans un grand
jour
ça c'est certain
il se bat et ça
et je fais dame G7 dame
ouais
7 voilà 4 et j'ai 3 échec et
mature suivante il va le voir évidemment
colors il vérifie il a bien raison il a
4 minutes
il vérifie tout ça
alien
des confites en plus la même pas
d'échecs avec les Noirs il est même pas
3G6 MG7 3.5 G4 pour H4 d'un
proche-7 reprend H5 la même mais il a en
fait il y a plusieurs matchs il y a G4
aussi qui m'attendent j'ai quatre oh H4
mais non
il revient c'est la frayeur
parce qu'il a 27 secondes mais c'est
maths 5 pardon
F5 on a rien vu d'accord
[Musique]
souriant et incroyable franchement on
voit que là ce qui sort à l'IRESA on
voit
on voit
ah oui ta caméra qui a encore décalé
qu'on a eu la visite du
de on a eu la visite de Jules et j'ai dû
j'ai dû tout rechanger
mais qui reviendra dès demain
aussi qui a perdu aussi qui peut sans
vouloir beaucoup plus que Jules là sur
ce match parce que il avait vraiment
c'est largement ça
au niveau des maths on a on a du coup
Jules qui a perdu contre un photographe
on a furosa qui a perdu contre Collard
on a Nakamura qui a perdu contre vent de
Forest et on avait l'autre match c'était
shimanov qui a perdu contre karwana et
donc ça fait quand même deux grosses
surprises dans ce match entre filles
ventes Forest et en plus le pire que ces
deux joueurs Nakamura et Furiosa vont se
rejouer demain dans la poule des
perdants et que le perdant sera
complètement éliminé de la compétition
donc c'est c'est un peu ouf parce que
c'était vraiment deux des joueurs pour
nous en tout cas les plus forts
de manière en éliminer ce qui est sûr
alors demain pour faire un petit récap
au niveau des des résultats on va voir
ventes Forest en
demi-finale
contre Colars donc qui vient de battre
firous ja on aura karwana contre
aussi en demi-finale et dans les dans le
on va dire la poule des perdants on a
Nakamura firuzza et shimanov Moussa
voilà donc bon
que des matchs très très chaud je pense
que je vois aucun à favori dans tous les
dans tous les matchs qu'on a annoncé et
donc
après c'est toujours pas clair tu vois
c'est que des matchs pas si clairs et
même même la gare écoute je pense qu'il
est pas content de jouer ou quoi
ah mais non clairement et non mais
encore maintenant
dommage vraiment pour aller raisin parce
que il peut s'en vouloir
il a pas été il a pas été bon
aujourd'hui
son moi je reste convaincu que son
enchère était quand même très très
risqué aussi de l'Armageddon 820 ouais
c'est pas bon écoute la dernière il a
gagné la dernière mais il joue que j'ai
8 tu vois
qu'il est pas tu vois il était pas
dedans aujourd'hui donc voilà il y a
quand même grâce à son talent il a quand
même fait durer le match et ça failli
passer mais c'est pas c'est pas immérité
pour pour colors loin de là
on se retrouve demain demain
ma mère demain 17h
avant 17h donc
16h50 on prend 16h45 16h50 on prend
l'antenne et ensuite tout ça les deux
Français ça va être beau merci beaucoup
et merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
évidemment et merci beaucoup à toi take
texto
ben de rien et puis demain un petit peu